we got a pretty special Friday for y'all
we got some big news Democrats seem very
desperate to stop the Banning of tick
tock which seems likely I don't know if
likely is the right word plausible
possible feasible but we'll see because
we're now starting to see some pretty
serious resistance but along with the
cultural manipulation there's data
privacy concerns though I think the
cultural cultural manipulation is the
most important now in terms of what we
are doing to win this culture War it
goes beyond just whinging on the
internet first if you cut if you caught
the culture War podcast earlier today I
am joining a lawsuit against California
for censorship and uh this could get big
minds.com is also a party to this
lawsuit basically California is
requiring platforms to create terms that
would you know let's just say
effectively interfere with free speech
so I'm going to be joining that lawsuit
fighting back I am also uh you're
usually not supposed to do this but I'll
say it anyway
we are beginning the preliminary stages
of filing litigation against band camp
for the termination of our account and
I'll explain for a few important things
and again you know I'll confer with my
legal counsel as to what the direct
approach is but here here are the
personal complaints that I think are
legitimate and fair
I don't know if the people who paid for
the songs that I've produced have access
to those songs which means I have no
idea who my customers are I have no idea
if they if they need a refund I have no
idea if they still have the product some
people have said they still have the
song well if that's the case then
bandcamp is hosting my content my
copyright without my permission and
using it to profit off profit off of me
by providing that content to individuals
in the long term with while terminating
my account so I think we've got some
very serious problems plus the
withholding of data I believe it's
likely they're withholding money from us
because they're not communicating with
us so we're going to have to go into
some very serious litigation against
them so we're gonna be pushing back but
uh before we get into all of the news
and the talk of cultural stuff there is
another big announcement today we
launched our fourth song Bright Eyes to
a tremendous response head over to
trashouserecords.com and you can pick up
the song notice we're we're not using
bandcamp anymore because they removed us
clearly whatever it is we're doing in
the culture war is effective we released
three songs before this all all three
charted on Billboard that's a 100
percent song on Billboard right I'm sure
most bands would love to have reached
that granted we put out like three
singles they've all done really well
we're hoping that bright eyes the latest
song we put out hits billboard as well
and you can help make that happen by
going to trashhouserecords.com and
downloading the song for I think the
minimum is 69 cents but you can put in
whatever whatever price you want uh we
wanna we wanna chart we want to prove
that we uh are having a cultural
influence and an impact and uh I think
currently we're number 24 on iTunes with
zero promotion so we've put out no you
know uh you know with the with the last
releases we did promos with you know
through all the videos throughout the
day we didn't do that today and we we
hit number 24 in the top 100 on iTunes
already I'm pretty sure with all of your
support right now buying the song we'll
probably hit number one maybe we'll see
we hit number one with the past two
songs we even beat out Taylor Swift
briefly
I'm hoping that we can once again do it
but it's entirely up to you if you guys
want to support our cultural Endeavors
buy the song at trash house records and
I think the reason that we got banned
from band camp is likely because
they don't care that much When We
complain on the internet because
complaining does very little but if we
make successful cultural products that
influence people and get people talking
and become popular they are actually
then losing the culture War so when all
these Outlets are like uh oh how are we
supposed to ignore the third song from
timcast that has hit billboard I mean
it's become really weird when people are
like how are they not I mean isn't that
a big deal how many bands have pulled
that one off so if we get a fourth song
in a row let's just we'll just keep
trying to do it so
that's if you if you if you think we
should and if you think we should trash
house records.com I would be greatly
appreciated but of course we'll promote
it more uh next week and we'll we'll
talk with Carter about the song and
we've got Pete Parada on drums Phil
Labonte of course he's been on the show
a bunch he uh his guest appearance in
the music video and so it is what it is
support our work don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
here to talk to us about winning the
culture War because again it's more than
just whinging it's someone who's
actually very successful and has taken a
very powerful stand to fight back in
that culture War we have Ethan van
skiver hey all right great to be here on
timcast Amazing absolutely thanks for
coming who are you what do you do okay
so like you said my name is Ethan Vance
Sky Vermin 30-year veteran of the comic
book industry as I say in my own show
world's most Charming disarming elegant
eloquent and yet humble man great big
Sopranos fan of trusted member of the
media not as trusted as you though I
think that you're more trusted than I am
at this point and rightly so by the
corporate press uh maybe by Regular
People yeah that's all that matters uh
yeah I am a comic book artist I work for
Marvel in DC I've drawn Green Lantern
and Flash mostly some X-Men stuff in my
time uh I was viciously canceled for
voting for Trump in 2017. uh everybody
kind of knew uh that I was a republican
uh but when I voted for Trump and Trump
won and then I celebrated that was a
bridge too far the mechanism I did
celebrate I took a nice picture of
myself in a mega hat posted on Twitter
people were outraged by that I didn't
understand because I was so polite when
Obama won yep I was so polite so uh for
people who aren't familiar you're an
artist and you created the Flash's mom
yeah you created atrocities yeah are
there any other Walker lar fleas like if
you've been reading Green Lantern and uh
you know some people in the chat
probably have uh we did something called
the emotional Spectrum back in uh uh
2009 or so and what it was was we
realized the Green Lantern uh his green
energy represents willpower then there's
yellow energy which represents fear and
boy it really seems like those two
colors are real close on the rainbow
right and maybe there are other colors
as well yeah so we created Red Lanterns
orange lanterns the yellow lanterns uh
all the way to the Violet red and uh
they all represented a different sort of
motivation red was rage blue was hope
yellow Was Fear uh wasn't there like
white like a combination there was and
that's why there are now white power
ranks uh that are on the market wait
what you got to make a villain called
that's a real story I remember this is
true I'm so sorry DC I'm so sorry about
this but it is true and I guess it's
part of my Legend you know look if
they're green power rings and there are
white lanterns there there are white
power rings and you can find those on uh
paste you can find those on eBay I guess
so uh anyway yeah I created all that
stuff all those characters uh are you
know associated with that
uh and did very very well for DC all the
symbols associated with those characters
uh t-shirts baseball caps all the stuff
there it was a marketing Bonanza uh
isn't there a Black Lantern Corps as
well and it's like yes zombies yeah all
of the DC heroes and villains that died
uh you know we resurrected them we gave
them Black Lantern rings and they came
back and bedeviled the heroes and the
the prophecy of blackest night it was so
much fun I mean we really got people
excited because the idea that we gave to
DC Comics was this superpower that's
transferable to any other character
imagine how this lights somebody's
imagination on fire that you know if you
get a Red Lantern ring you can put it on
Wolverine a Marvel character and he's
suddenly Red Lantern Wolverine and he's
spitting up red energy and he's crazy
and wild uh the Hulk might have a Red
Lantern ring this is just great for
Comics so those are Marvel characters
but it just is great and DC just loved
the hell out of it they did so much
great stuff with like the uh the
emotional spectrum and all the different
colors and all the different rings but
then you voted for Trump so
I'd like to make a character called
ultraviolet that's has the ring they
already did it oh nice does it make it
partially invisible uh I don't know okay
well we'll we'll get through this and
we'll get into it we got we got uh right
now somebody hanging out what is going
on guys it's been a while it's been a
very long time since I've uh I've been
on here yes uh I do pop culture crisis
Monday through Friday 3 P.M Eastern
Standard Time right here on YouTube you
should join us there I remember that
story about the the white about the
white power rings and all the meat there
was all these memes being made it's it's
a guy going and says like DC
headquarters and says how many days
since DC last time DC screwed something
up and they tear it off and started over
again I remember that right on we got uh
hi everyone good to see you Ian crossing
here on a Friday night let's steamroll
this what's up everybody it's Kellen um
Ethan if you need to you can move this
mic uh closer to you further from you
sound great yeah just put it right below
your mouth move it around with you
whenever you're oh I'm gonna use it to
cover as much of myself as I can if
that's okay with you yeah
all right let's jump into this first
story
you know I saw this from Politico and I
don't know if they're gonna ban Tick
Tock but I personally think Tick Tock
should be banned for a variety of
reasons and there there is a there's a
difficult question but
you know we don't want to curtail free
speech Politico reports will Tick-Tock
be banned some Dems say not so fast the
number of house Democrats and at least a
few Senators remain unconvinced that
singling out the Chinese owned app is
the best course of action right well
we'll see what happens I don't know
exactly but let me explain to you why I
think this is happening I think the
Democratic party and the culture War
cultural left represent
zombification social zombification
zombies crave only to spread the zombie
disease there's no end goal so if you
look at the issue of tick tock there is
legitimate problems with allowing a CCP
product into the hands of our children
the cultural manipulation in China the
kids there are their version of tick
tock has educational science that kind
of stuff really great for our young
developing mind in the United States
there's young women who think they're
Birds saying they are bird person and
their pronouns are bockbuck or something
like that there's the woman who's like
frog frog self pronouns these things are
being propagated on the American version
which is literally harming vulnerable
people to the point where you notice a
lot of the trans people the trans
species people people who actively want
surgeries are autistic and extremely
vulnerable Tick Tock is doing that you
then have the data spying component the
fact that Democrats would defend this
despite the fact that they are clear
obvious and objective problems with it
shows the zombification of the party if
it power empowers them they don't care
the damage it causes they want to
extract from the system so I think it
should be banned and the main reason is
not so much the data spying which I
think is a problem but the cultural
influence
we and that's probably why the social
zombies want to maintain it it spreads
social zombism and mental illness so
this is this is a big issue right now if
we want to win the culture War there is
a political and technological component
right here granted I think creating
culture is the number one way to do it
and pushing back but it's hard if the
mechanisms for delivering that content
are controlled by say the CCP
what's interesting is first of all I
heard earlier somebody mentioned to us I
mentioned the the fact that China has a
different algorithm for their version of
tick tock than we do right and somebody
said that Andrew Schultz said that he
started that as a conspiracy theory so
that was actually him that started the
stem rumor that they had that they had a
different version of the algorithm is
that even if that's true uh it doesn't
matter because the damage it's doing
here in America whether China was
getting the same stuff as we are not I
can't say if that's true somebody said
that to us when we were on the show
earlier uh I I think a lot of it's also
The Addictive nature of it as much of
the you talk zombification I talk the
addictive nature of phones of technology
and just how much damage it's doing for
people to have to use this technology
constantly all the time every day well
let me just say I mean uh you know if
Espionage uh isn't the issue I gotta ask
them what makes Tick Tock different from
what Tim's talking about than YouTube
shorts which is basically adopting the
same delivery system is Tick-Tock highly
addictive
short videos I mean essentially
uh it's the same thing it's the same
product so why is that not a problem in
Tick Tock that's a good point and that's
why this bill that's been introduced
into the Senate it's called the restrict
Act is so dangerous because there really
isn't much of a difference in these
companies if you start generally
targeting social media companies for
doing or for people doing things you
don't like on those networks it gives
you carte blanche to just start ending
networks ending Tick Tock ending Twitter
we're Banning Twitter we're banning
YouTube because somebody on YouTube said
that the election was fake like I I'm
reading this bill it's called the
restrict act maybe we can pull this up
at some point and there's a few sections
in the restrict act that are completely
insane section three where we have
section uh three one C is insane
it's Section 3 A1C what it says is
oh my God this is so crazy dude this is
like the Patriot Act for technology
basically this is it cannot we cannot
allow this kind of what does it do power
it gives the Secretary of Commerce the
ability to
oh God it's so okay so let's see section
3A the secretary in consultation with
the relevant executive department agency
has authorized to and she'll take action
to identify deter disrupt prevent
prohibit investigate or otherwise
mitigate
uh these Technologies is what they're
saying if they pose and undue or
unacceptable risk of interfering with
the result uh or reported result of a
federal election and they're saying like
if a person this is any any covered
transaction by any person or with
respect to any property subject to the
jurisdiction in the United States so any
American citizen that says an election
was fake on Twitter means that they can
go into mitigating any any mitigating uh
act that they can take to to solve that
meaning they could shut Twitter down I
don't think that Andrew Schultz thing is
true I mean the reporting going back
talks about how the algorithm is
controlled by the Chinese Communist
party so I pulled up Fox uh multiple
sources I had always heard that they had
said that they had a different algorithm
in China than we have for our version of
tick tock it was just something somebody
said earlier and I said I could see
somebody like leading with something
like that making a joke like that and
Catching Fires somehow there's no way
there was also reporting like two or
three years ago which we we talked about
so this is probably like two years ago
about how how they were specifically
trying to ban feminists and feminist
ideas from their from their schools and
stuff like that so maybe the specific
concept of Academia of stem content yeah
he may have made up I don't know I can't
I can't verify I don't know there's no
way
I mean so so Joe Rogan made the claim
which popularized it yeah so perhaps
Schultz lied to Joe and then Joe ran
with it but there is previous reporting
that so that where people are saying do
yen is is China's version of tick tock
has a very different algorithm that's
that doesn't allow this kind of content
it doesn't specify stem or anything like
that though think of all the influencers
that will be out of a job if they ban it
here in America
what will they do but you don't make you
don't make real money on Tick Tock you
make like they push you towards brand
deals though right they a large amount
of following gets them more content with
other types of products that they sell
through their let me put it this way you
can make money on Tick Tock you can make
money on Instagram in terms of social
media I think YouTube is the highest
um like viewed a dollar ratio yeah and
it's still crappy podcasts are the best
audio version podcasts have like the
best CPM if you want to make money on
ads and sponsorships it's audio podcasts
Instagram reels actually do fairly well
for mid-level creators and down right
probably not for the larger ones because
there's a cap on how much you can make
per uh per month
Facebook does way better yeah so putting
putting your videos on Facebook makes
like 10 times the money of Instagram
yeah like per viewer it was weird don't
ask me why I don't know well Tick Tock
was completely worthless that's why I'm
I personally think Tick Tock in my
personal opinion
I believe it is probable that tick
tock's followers are fake
and intended to socially manipulate
young dude this is coming out of China
which said that Cove had zero covet they
were like we have no more covet now it's
all done like they just lie lie lie
analytically lie I think the one of the
the biggest black pills for me was in
somebody on Facebook like long before I
got rid of Facebook was like actually so
China's got the right idea by locking
people in their homes I'm like I'm
that's enough internet for today like up
like somebody I've known for a long
period of time here's here's what's
going to happen there's going to be
another lockdown and then someone's
gonna make a video on Tick Tock and it's
gonna say I feel kind of bad this
doesn't seem like a good thing to do we
shouldn't be locking down
then the phone's going to go
and they're going to look and it's
people going to be saying that they're
going to get a bunch of notifications
from people being like this ain't it bro
you're wrong are you trying to destroy
the planet bro you're so off I can't
believe I ever followed you then they're
gonna be like oh what's happening why is
everybody mad at me then they're gonna
make a video and being like you know I
thought about it man like we probably do
need to lock down and then like like
like wow you're so smart you're so smart
that's what the Bots do Sargon posted
like a poll the other day that said a
bunch of people in Britain said when
they said like do you believe that the
the lockdowns were a mistake and most of
them said no
like I I don't know how big the sample
size was in a poll like that but like
even with hindsight being 20 20 it's
just you're living in a different world
than people of uh who intake a different
set of news to you so somebody watching
CNN or over there I guess the the BBC
they don't understand things the way you
understand about what's been going on in
the world so functionally they might see
the another lockdown is a good idea
because they just don't get that things
are different now straight up it's a
manipulation Tool uh Tick Tock we don't
have access to the algorithm so we don't
know what it's feeding us why it's
feeding us what it's feeding us we don't
know what's getting tracked with our
data so that stuff needs to be opened up
we need to see that code that I
understand we could use the government
to force open but to do these dumb Bland
General legal things where it gives them
they can they can mitigate any system
that quote poses an undue or
unacceptable risk to the National
Security of the United States are you
kidding me that is absolutely insane do
you do you use tick tock I have a tick
tock but I don't use too much of a
boomer sorry I'm on I'm on YouTube I
think I think you're a gen xer yeah yeah
exactly right yeah but it's like you
don't you don't need to see the code to
know that Doom scrolling is bad that
like you'll find yourself like 10
minutes go by and you're like holy crap
what the hell have I been doing for the
last 10 minutes and like I go through
phases like that right where like not
Tick Tock but like I there's a
difference between posting content and
then when you where you find you've just
been rolling and looking at nothing
important for 15 minutes you're not even
really engaging with what you're looking
at but you always feel worse for wear
when you're done and that's just as much
as you're talking about as it it
incentivizes people to act or promote
bad behavior or to promote unhealthy
Behavior it is mentally damaging for
your brain even if you're taking in
general content to sit there and doing
scroll for long periods of time what was
that thing called that you talk about
all the time apoptosis is that what
apoptosis when a cell programs itself to
die because it has no more function in
the system I feel like Democrats the
party of that right like every single
thing I shouldn't say everything but
like most of their policies are just
about killing their constituents like
abortion sterilization or now Tick Tock
it's like promoting the things that
maximize the likelihood an individual
suffers and then dies
that or just the fact that people who
use it tend to vote that way and it
encourages them to reach out to more
people that's what I mean like if their
policies result in people ending their
bloodlines they're like just basically
the Democratic party is the great filter
of social Darwinism well that's what
they talk about with lgbtqia philosophy
right they don't give birth they recruit
and then the people who are resistant to
those ideas have families and persist
and their bloodlines continue I worry
sometimes though like we've talked about
how they say gen gen Z is going to be
the first generation in a long time that
will be more conservative I don't know
if that's beared out to be true but a
lot of times I wonder it's like the the
power of social media you can have all
the kids you want that kid is still
going to have a phone at 12 years old If
the parents don't do the right thing
that kid's still gonna have a phone too
young and they're going to have access
to material that's very damaging them to
have access to if they don't have
parents that are showing them the right
way to live you gotta get out of the
Cities you gotta harmful your kids yep
but let's talk about uh some of the
stuff that we can do and pushing back
it's not just about complaining the
internet like we often do so a few
things we're uh uh we did it we did a
podcast episode the culture War bill
ottman was here we're talking with uh
James Lawrence lawyer we are suing
California because California passed a
law that has requirements on big Tech
platforms are basically requiring
censorship which negatively impacts me
as a media company and and content
creator for distribution on these
platforms and then Bill who's the CEO of
one of these big platforms so we're
actually taking the steps to do
something because we're not just sitting
around doing nothing we're likely going
to be entering litigation filing
lawsuits against
um band camp for terminating our account
because they've created a whole slew of
problems for us and all of the tens of
thousands of people who've purchased
music I think I think it may be in the
thousands possibly tens of thousands
so it's created a disaster you know and
the way we described it is like if you
if if you have like uh if you go to a
mall
and you sign a contract to open up a
mall store and sell a product and then
without breaking any of the rules of the
malls contract or any of the deal one
day you walk up and they've chained your
they've pulled the gate down locked it
shut they've changed the locks and
you're like I've got stuff in there and
they're like too bad it's ours now and
you're like yo yeah at the very least
you have to give me my stuff back like
you can't just take my stuff what was
the reason they gave you they didn't
give you no so so we don't even know if
they're still holding our money we don't
know if they're still Distributing our
content or hosting our copyright our
copyrighted Works without a permission
or profiting off of it because they've
communicated nothing so our only course
of action is going to be
if like that's what I'm saying the mall
analogy if they shut the store and we
know for a fact our stuff is in there
and we do because we had music on the
platform well so the first thing is yo
you have to let us in to go and check to
see where our stuff is we own the rights
that's our copyrighted work
with the mall they'd let you go in and
say look your stuff's not there I mean
granted you know if you have an ice
cream machine and you didn't get it you
know it's there with us the problem now
is we can't contact any of the people
who bought from us
not directly so we don't we don't know
how to refund if they need a refund so
if they don't have the music then
bandcamp took a percentage of the money
that transferred and then
took the music away from the people okay
that's a problem because now we've got
to Pro like that that's like theft or
something I don't know that's
interesting and then if they didn't take
the music away now I've got a problem
because they're hosting my copyrighted
content and profiting off of it by
hosting it on their platform for people
without my without my involvement so
we've got a legal a legal issue that
needs to be answered by the courts can a
business
host my copyrighted content after
removing me from the platform if it
retains a customer base that they are
profiting off of so there's there's a
real question that's to be answered I I
forgot what it's called but we talked
about it anyway we're taking these
actions we're suing we're also building
culture we released a song pick it up at
trashhouserecords.com but uh this is
what brings uh brings us to you Ethan
you got this comic cyber cyber frog ever
too that's the second one yeah Rec
Planet let's let's talk about your story
first with uh with getting canceled so
people can understand what Comics gate
is and uh why they should they should
hear your story because I know a lot of
people uh may not be familiar uh where's
my where'd my pen go is it this one that
is awesome so uh basically you are
responsible for some of the most iconic
uh comic book imagery I like that I
don't know if it's true but I yeah well
so so you created Flash's mother Nora
well that's one thing yeah I know right
but hold on
the movie that's coming out The Flash
movie yeah it's about him going back to
save his mom is it not right I think so
yeah Flashpoint Paradox that's a a major
DC storyline right where the flash his
mother was killed by zoom and then he
wants to go back in time because he can
run so fast he can do it so this is a
character you created now so influential
there's a major massive you know
Blockbuster film about to be released I
think that's that's important context
people to understand the amount of
influence you've had on the industry is
is large Plus in the in the video game
that came out a few years ago Injustice
two atrocitus is a character who is in
it you can play as him a character that
you you drew you created the art for uh
yeah I created the whole thing I'll take
a hundred percent credit for atrocities
yeah I just I had the name I said this
is so DC Comics atrocitus it sounds
great so you actually created the
character absolutely yeah and then one
day you said hey everybody I voted for
Trump and they then they they came after
you well they they knew I was a
republican I mean they did I stood I
mean I literally was the only elephant
in the room all the time when I went to
comic book conventions and everybody
looked at me weird I would have friends
I would make friends with other
professionals and then I would I I don't
know we'd spend a little time apart and
then the next time I'd see them they'd
go
you voted for Bush
and they'd have this look of disgust
about them that I was like yes I'm a
republican I voted I voted for Bush uh
and then that was fine I think the Obama
years were great because uh for me
anyway because I wasn't being persecuted
I that nobody was worried about anything
because Obama was President they won uh
and Trump was a joke I really didn't
think much of trump in 2015 but he won
me over by 2016 and I was a fan and I
love the Pepe memes I loved all that
stuff uh so uh anyway it was no big deal
until Trump actually won and when Trump
won I just thought great it's our turn
you know very naive about the culture
War were my Maga hat that was
autographed by the president and I took
a nice picture and I tweeted it out and
that's when I started to see I started
to see messages from my peers saying
things like Ethan's Maga Ethan Vance Guy
versus Maga did you see that yeah well I
guess he's canceled now right everybody
he's canceled and I didn't know what
that was all about but but there was
definitely like rage over this idea that
somebody who was a fairly influential
artist at DC Comics was a trump
supporter and uh I didn't think it was
gonna you know I basically talked to a
few of them and kind of said hey this is
the way oh God I'm so naive I said this
is the way the country moves forward
right step left step you know basically
we all get our turn and hopefully you
know this is progress
but then I got a message from somebody
who said
how could you do this you voted against
all of your queer comrades and Comics
how do you understand that our lives are
in are in Jeopardy and you voted for
that don't you care
and I guess I wrote back to that person
and I kind of said uh well uh I guess I
don't care that much about that I guess
I have a priorities in my life then you
know you're we all have our different
you know issues that we vote on uh
anyway my response to that tweet or that
private message got shared around to all
my peers and now everybody was furious
with me because I'd basically
invalidated the lives of my queer
Associates and Comics uh and then the
final thing was I was persecuted people
were coming after me
um
I had a writer I was working with on
Batman I was doing Batman for a little
while this great guy named Greg hurwitz
and he had a mutual friend he had a uh
Jordan B Peterson was his friend and he
kind of said have you heard of this guy
Jordan Peterson I said yes he's great
you know well he's seen your work he
likes it he wants to know if you'll
illustrate his upcoming book and uh I
was just like well if I do that if I do
it I'm gonna get a weapon I know it you
know that's going to be a big problem
I'm already on the verge of cancellation
I was terrified uh my wife and I just
had a baby who was diagnosed with autism
and so I needed my job I really needed
my job but on the other hand I had this
conversation with Jordan Peterson
where he said something that really
impacted me and I still think about this
every single day and it helps me step
forward it helps me take another step he
said Ethan I said I'm scared Dr Peterson
I'm scared to illustrate your book
and he just said uh Ethan you can't let
these mobbers back you into a corner I
wish I could do a Canadian accent for
you you can't let these mobbers back you
into a corner and I just thought to
myself
you're damn right you know I'm gonna
illustrate your book and so I did I
Illustrated 12 rules for life it turned
out to be a number one bestseller and
that was it I have the uh someone sent
me the Korean version really yeah I
guess it was a joke
I can't read Korean though it may have
burned some bridges or seems to have it
that it launched your career in so many
other ways that book is huge it was it
was big but again it wasn't really my
book it was Jordan Peterson's book and
people just kind of incidentally go oh
your name's in that like my little
sister Hannah who's a big fan of yours
she's watching right now hi Hannah howdy
uh you know she she was shocked she's
like we love that book I can't believe
my brother Illustrated it like I just
you know so um uh in any case like that
it's more stuff like that but what it
really did was it just kind of like set
my feet in stone like I am now
officially I guess a culture Warrior
where I didn't even believe the culture
War existed until then wow uh and here
was this 2017 2017. and I said people
were calling me a white supremacist and
a Nazi and all these things that in 2017
really hurt you didn't want to be called
a Nazi you didn't want people to think
you were racist and but those are the
weapons that they use against creative
people and pretty much anyone that they
want to destroy nobody you can't deny
that you're racist it's racism is on a
spectrum so is white supremacy and If
you deny it that proves it in in a sense
yes it does the cockatrap you're not
even aware that you're racist let me
explain why you're racist so it really
is a a nasty situation and um
in any case uh DC Comics called me up
and it was uh I gotta say DC did the
best they could but they were being
swarmed by the media uh over my
existence working there uh the thing
that leftists do that they're so great
at is they have accomplices in the media
that will write the articles that you
want them to write that they want them
to write and then those will get
published on The Daily Beast or any of
these awful like websites uh and then
they'll refer to those articles as proof
that you are exactly who they say you
are and then those get referenced in
Wikipedia your Wikipedia is soon
denouncing you as a whatever it is so
white supremacist or whatever they're
calling you
uh and uh anyway
um so that was uh that was that DC
Comics called me up and God bless them
they they tried to stand by me as much
as they could but uh somebody who I
really like their friend of the family
called me up and I said am I okay is
everything okay and I could hear him
pouring a drink into a little glass I
could hear the ice and he just said we
can't renew your contract wow and uh he
took a big drink and I was like I have a
child I have a baby I have a baby with
autism I need my job and he said well
you've got four or five more issues on
your contract and then that's it we
gotta you got time to find other work
you know
so it was absolutely terrifying you know
you know what the mistake you made was
what well you see with the you know the
left would have a leftist would have
done what they would have immediately
started yelling how dare you touch me
you ever you ever watch Fight Club yes
you know the scene where Edward Norton
falls on the Groundhog's punching
himself in the face yeah that's what the
left does yeah so then they walk out and
then people are like I saw him walk out
with a black eye and then you're like
you're gonna renew my content that's
what they do cry bullies right they say
they they they accuse the boss of some
kind of impropriety they exploit the law
the EEOC uh the labor rights and stuff
like that whereas you and on the sky
just went well I guess my contract's
done I guess I'll leave yeah but you
know one thing I don't like is when
people use the word can't that's really
annoying when when what it means is I
don't want to we don't want to but we're
like we can't refer your contract no
they could they just chose not to they
could have but who am I uh I mean they
were DC Comics was in all kinds of
trouble they were trying to sign with
the ATM I'm making excuses for them they
were trying to sell themselves to ATT
they were trying to get good press and
they were deliberately the left was
deliberately putting all this stuff in
the media to make it look like they were
employing white supremacists they really
didn't have as a business a choice and I
I give them a pass I do because they
were they've always been good to my
family up until the end and they're
still writing me big royalty checks for
movies like The Flash that are wow
really yeah that's cool that's nice yeah
yeah well certainly with a t for like a
year and the rating sold again yeah so I
don't don't answer this if you can't I'm
curious
maybe you can answer in a more General
sense you know
so the flat with The Flash movie you're
getting like a royal TF from that
somehow I'll bet yeah so I'm like how
does that I I want to avoid asking
anything too personal but I'm curious
like a comic book artist who sees their
work turn into a movie like what kind of
money can they make from that is it like
a big deal is it like you're gonna buy a
mansion or is it like you might pay a
phone bill oh oh no we bought our house
from the Justice League royalties so
from the movie yeah yeah wow wow so wait
wait how did like how do you get
royalties for that because when you drew
the pictures you have the right to that
imagery so because of the the insane
exploitation of comic book creators
throughout the years uh you know I mean
basically Steve ditko doesn't own
Spider-Man or Doctor Strange at all he's
got none of that he should be a
billionaire and he died you know just a
regular middle class fella it doesn't
make any sense uh DC Comics kind of woke
up to that idea and they um they created
an incentive program for their creators
if you just want to sit there and draw
their characters that fine you'll get a
paycheck but if you want to create
something for them like I always did I
always created new stuff for them if
they look at it and say this is really
good we're going to be using this in
other media they'll send you an
incentive contract that you signed that
grants you a percentage of those media
rights in perpetuity that's awesome in
perpetuity that's the way it should be
yeah yeah so there are certain things
like I own Iron Heights Prison from so
whenever flash sends a criminal to jail
it's an iron Heights I get paid so it's
great it's true wow but I have to
imagine it's like one instance in one
media thing it's the combined collection
of all the different media mentioning it
that makes it substantial like video
games are very substantial I mean yeah
the the conglom the combined uh you know
that definitely matters but movies and
video games are insane the royalties we
get for video games are great I hear
that's for a musician if they can get
their song into a movie is when they can
retire yeah I I there was a a friend of
a friend so someone I know knows a band
that we would widely consider to be a
one-hit wonder and the guy I think made
like 10 million dollars off of one song
that ended up in a commercial
it was a very very popular song most of
them may have may have remembered it
from the 2000s
but like they told me the story was like
this guy went from being a middle class
dude playing local shows building up a
following making a decent living then
one day a phone company bought a song
from him and then he just didn't know
what to do and he just had 10 million
bucks like the money just slapped his
account and he was like that's weird and
it kind of in a sense destroyed his life
as I'm told in that
a buddy of mine said that you know when
he first became very wealthy at a young
age he had an existential crisis because
you don't know what to do everyone
around you is in this machine the
relationships that you had were
predicated upon like your work
environment your school environment but
now you've been removed from that and
you're just some dude who wanders around
it doesn't have to work where everyone
else is like you know the story is he'd
call up his friend on like a Monday
afternoon and be like hey you want to go
out to eat and they'd be like bro I'm at
work I need to go oh when you get off
they're like I don't know six or seven
then I'm going home to see my family and
go oh so all you rich people out there
when you take your friends out to lunch
or dinner whatever let them know before
the meal that you're gonna pay for it
it's so stressful to wonder the entire
meal when you're broke am I gonna have
to pay for this I don't know what I can
order so just let them know ahead of
time it's been helpful and also
be wary of inviting your friends on
trips to Europe
like I I've seen that way too much well
like people who are wealthier being like
you have any you have any time this
weekend we're going to Prague it's like
uh-huh
dude is it on you yeah right what are
you asking me yeah I mean yeah so I
think people need to be cognitive I
think you know I know a lot of people
who grew up well off do not understand
that's not a normal thing people do
right and also I know exactly what
you're talking about Ian because you
know when I work for like these media
companies they'd be like hey let's go
out to dinner and they would bring
people from the room like from the from
the from work who are making like maybe
80k a year but they'd want to go to like
a five-star Steakhouse and get like
wagyu or something and then I'm just
like you realize you can't bring that
like that's not that's not nice that's
like a mean thing to do you know
anyway it hasn't made you crazy these
royalties and the wealth I mean maybe a
little bit you know uh but uh no I mean
listen uh it's uh it's really nice of
them I'm really happy that DC is taking
care of more of their uh professional
creators and who's your favorite
character you created
um I guess it's atrocities just because
he's so popular and I really I don't
know I just like him he I I got the idea
I was watching 28 Days Later remember
those boys like the zombies just spit
blood and their eyes are red and they're
they're all of the the the mucous
membrane and tears it's all blood and
red and I just got this idea this is the
Red Lantern course this is I'm sure you
guys don't talk to many people like me
this is how I am but here's the whole
thing imagine here's the fantasy imagine
you are wronged in such a profoundly
awful way uh somebody kills your wife
your kid you know blah blah you go
through the legal system uh and nothing
happens there's you can't get your
Justice right and the guy's just
laughing at you that did it there he is
there's atrocities uh and so
um you're so angry obviously you're
filled with this rage that you've you
can't even comprehend
but then a little red ring flies down
from outer space and looks at you and
talks to you and says put me on and
together we'll get the Vengeance that
you're looking for that you deserve
now do you put the ring on
you do that because the minute you put
the ring on you are now overwhelmed with
rage to the point where you're spitting
up like red blood and energy and
everything and now you're entirely
consumed by Vengeance you've become the
Incredible Hulk essentially and yes you
know you get your revenge you can go get
this guy and punish him and Destroy his
whole world
but now you've lost your soul and that's
what the Red Lantern Corps is all about
like it's a it's this Faustian bargain
that comes with putting on the ring can
you take the ring off the ring leaves
you when it's ready when it's destroyed
you you know it's like it leaves you now
somebody like atrocities has just
mastered the ring he wears it all the
time it's never going to leave him he's
the leader of the Red Lantern Corps
let me ask you about uh you know before
all the stuff went down did you notice
in the industry before your cancellation
and encroaching wokeness
cult-like mentality yeah yeah yeah uh
but I didn't understand what it was uh a
lot of uh a lot of
strange women I hate to put it this way
sorry ladies uh a lot of strange women
kind of suddenly showed up in the comic
book business and basically came at us
with this criticism that this was
clearly a boys club it was unsafe for
women and everything that you guys are
putting out is sexist and it's racist
and it's homophobic and well we're going
to fix that if you hire us and you
should hire Russ we're going to fix that
because if you don't high-risk your
sexes so suddenly all of these women
show up and they start basically
making changes to this sort of male
dominated hobby this is this is a
male-driven culture obviously obviously
it is these power fantasies are mostly
for boys but they started to make these
changes uh the women suddenly who used
to be beautiful and curvaceous we used
to be able to glorify and exaggerate the
female form suddenly we had to cover
them up breasts became smaller and
smaller until they were just sort of
pecs there was actually a weird
phenomenon called the uni pack which was
just one breast with like a stretched
cloth over it because you didn't even
want to Define breasts in any way in
superheroes uh and basically everybody
got scared and then this other thing
happened
um because there were women in the
workplace of course the men started
flirting with the women uh you know God
helped them uh these guys started to ask
girls on dates and then the girls would
say that I was sexual harassment and
that's when cancel culture really
started I saw some very talented guys
get their lives turned upside down
because they were stupid enough to ask
so and so at the bar at a convention if
she wanted to come up to their hotel
room
uh and this wasn't like a powered uh
disparity there was one case where an
editor with a lot of power was putting
his hands on women I understand that
this was different this was a case of
peers we're both creators you're a
female I'm a male I'm gonna ask you on a
date
I feel threatened if I say no to you all
of this stuff that happened the me too
hit Comics pretty hard
so there was uh that whole situation
with which caused everybody to really
get in line you did not want to question
these women you didn't want to started
to realize they were activists you don't
want to question these activists at all
allow them to make these changes and
then the other thing that happened was
there was a guy named Orson Scott Card
who was a very very famous uh sci-fi
author and he's also Latter-Day Saint I
was raised Mormon so I know that he's
Latter-Day Saint so he shares the values
that I was raised with he came out and
said he disagreed with gay marriage you
didn't think it was something marriage
was something between a man and a woman
and it was a holy uh you know a holy
thing it shouldn't gay marriage
shouldn't be a thing
uh and then DC tried to hire him uh to
do a Superman story and the entire
industry went crazy trying to get this
Superman story a short story by this
legendary Orson Scott Card look him up
legendary uh author uh canceled and that
was an amazing thing to me I was like
why can't we just publish the story I
don't understand why disagreeing with
him about this one political idea means
that he can't write a Superman story
when everybody loves his work
so that's when I started to see woke
creeping into comics and uh you know by
the time
2015 rolled around
my peers were saying strange things to
me they were saying
uh you're a capitalist you're a
republican right Ethan you care about
money uh
imagine this 50 of the country fifty
percent of the world is made up of women
and we're not marketing to them at all
are we if we started marketing and
changing these Comics to appeal to more
women and hiring more women you
understand what would happen we would
double our income we would double our
revenue and you as somebody who cares
about money because you're a capitalist
and that's like aren't we all capital no
we're not okay just me uh that means
something to you I'm sure
and uh that was the philosophy that was
the big lie uh that allowed Comics to
come in and become woke uh I think from
there you you hire activists they hire
more activists and the whole thing
erodes from the inside and then people
stop buying yeah when you want to appeal
to women then the guys maybe are not
getting appealed to like you can't
appeal to both I would think there you
might be able to it's it's even weirder
than that Lego Lego did a study which I
always cite and this is amazing I don't
think anybody's thought of it this way
but Lego was wondering why girls don't
play with Lego toys they're boys but
they're not really gender based they're
just bricks so why are little boy he's
playing with Legos but girls aren't why
why is that so they got to study
together they got 2500 kids 1250 boys
1250 girls and their parents and they
put uh Lego figurines let's just say a
Batman Lego set in front of these kids
and they just studied how these boys and
girls played with their Lego toys to try
to figure out what the missing problem
was what was what's the missing piece
well the boys pick up Batman pick up a
little Batman figurine and they become
Batman that's the whole thing like they
like they take on those traits they
imagine they're Batman you know and
that's how boys fantasize that's how
boys play meanwhile the little girls
pick up Batman and Batman becomes them
they project themselves onto Batman and
suddenly Batman is acting like they are
wow which is why Barbie is so popular
what's Barbie's personality who's Barbie
he's whoever the little girl who's
playing with Barbie is we were just
talking about that yesterday boys
pretend that they are He-Man and girls
pretend that Barbie is them that's right
yeah wow I used to do that with GI Joes
I would become the guy duke or Scarlet
or whoever the character and we would
act like me and Steve we'd play we'd set
them all up and I'd be like I'm coming
and he's like no look out look out ah
and he'd be the Cobra Commander and like
we were acting as the characters I don't
know there was a I've never like put my
personality onto a doll before it's why
they say it where a lot of the
representation stuff comes in it's a
feminine trait that's been learned by
males to to look at representation as if
they have to see their exact selves in
another character I don't know if when I
played with Legos and stuff if I became
the character whatever like if I was
playing with Batman
Batman was doing Batman stuff you know
what I mean like I would have like
Batman and like Cyclops and I'd be
Batman would be like but Tim you knew
who they were they were themselves they
were themselves yeah they were not me as
them which is why as a as a male well I
mean like that's what I'm trying to say
like I wasn't going like I'm Batman and
I will fight you I was like I have
Batman Cyclops and Batman would be like
yeah dude like so they were two distinct
characters of themselves that I would
have do battle when I was were any of
them you no okay see that's the whole
thing that's what I'm saying like not
that I would be like I am Batman and
like walk around and project myself and
as like Batman becomes me I'm saying
like the I would view them as them as
their character of course but for the
girls you're saying like they would be
like look Jenny would be playing with
Batman she'd be like this is Jenny so
she'd have the Batman doll and that it
would be called Jenny and that would be
her like that kind of thing pretty much
I mean like whatever a little girl's
aspirations are uh she'll project them
onto Barbie
have distinct traits like Batman has
Batman his person Wayne Batman has
parents you know what I'm saying does
Barbie have distinct traits that they
would even be able to quantify other
than what their physical appearance is
deliberately no yeah that's why it's so
successful
so now imagine I don't think men and
women changes they grow older uh in in
that way that's just that's a big
difference between men and women so now
imagine that you're a creative person
who's writing Batman
uh now men just go okay well I'm gonna
write Batman as I know Batman he's going
to be Batman he's not going to be me I
don't want to put myself into Batman
he's going to be Batman I'm going to do
the best prime minister I can do
these ladies
Batman starts getting sassy they start
to write Batman with more of their own
traits and soon before you know it it's
like these characters are unrecognizable
they're sitting around having coffee in
bars and having Chit Chat and stuff and
it you know they they they're they seem
to be unable to actually and I'm not
saying all of them there are some ladies
who are great and the Senti shout out
Louise Simonson crate writers but many
of them are just
you know projecting themselves onto
these characters and maybe it's because
they really just don't care that much
are there specific examples of character
like a character you can think of that
was fact I could say feminized I don't
know if that's the right word we're not
talking about like masculine and
feminine Behavior it's not necessarily
men and women yeah but like well I I
I'll tell you one thing I don't like and
I don't know if this is actually a a
remnant of this but have you saw the
Batman film yes I absolutely hated it
really because the new one I think me
and you were the only people that didn't
like it because Batman was totally
incompetent it didn't make sense for his
character Batman Batman is something to
behold because he is the best of us he
is a human being who use light utilizes
the best technology strategy so to
create up but it's Batman early on he's
dumb as a box of rocks no he's always
had 10 intelligence was it recently not
in that area that's the point in the
movie superhero and when he's jumping
off the building and he falls and gets
hurt I'm like and then you had the woke
Selena Kyle White Privilege thing like
they just ruined what Batman was
that line was particularly bad because
the rest of the movie's dialogue was
written to be completely Evergreen
meaning that it could have taken place
at any time so even if you're even if
you haven't taken a bathroom break by
the time you're at the two hour and 37
second point of this extremely overly
long and overly self-indulgent art piece
uh masquerading as a superhero flick
that line just takes you out of it
completely question Ethan did you notice
when the women would come in and start
to change the system did they have kids
or were they childish their childless
largely yes something that someone
pointed out is that women that aren't
mothers tend to try to Mother society
and they get into HR and they'll try and
mother the company they'll try and like
protect and nurture and change and like
no that's racist do it this way do it
this you know I'll give you I'll give
you my experience working with women
it's very interesting uh I worked in an
office and I was the only male manager
and the office was having problems
and so Revenue was down my Approach was
our revenue is dropping if we do not
reassess and restructure what we are
doing we will cease to exist their
attitude was no everyone bunker down
huddled together and will wait out the
storm
and I thought that was interesting
because it was like the women were
adamant we're going to keep doing
exactly what we're doing and just
tighten up and my attitude was it's not
working anymore this strategy does not
work we have to adapt
so I wonder if that's a an element of a
difference in the male and female the
male we have to go out take the risk and
go on an adventure and there it theirs
was I mean think about it in in terms of
like an old tribal
situation the women wanting to huddle
together in the cave to protect each
other and the men wanting to go out and
Venture off and try and find new sources
of food or or you know some way to solve
the problem that's what kind of felt
like to me fascinating did you see the
did you watch the movie prey on Hulu uh
it was the The Predator remake that they
did last year with the girl I was one of
the few people that didn't like it
because I said her motivation at the
time period when that movie came out
made no sense that she wanted to go to
be a hunter just to prove she can like
that's not realistic and nobody would be
let's let's this is actually uh let's
address the male female motivation
Captain America versus Captain Marvel I
love this breakdown have you seen both
movies I imagine right yeah Captain
America let's talk about the cultural
success and I want everyone to
understand this and I want you to tell
your friends and I want you to buy the
movie and I want you to somehow make the
movie number one on Netflix or whatever
Captain America is a Marvel film from
about 10 years 10 years ago right more
than that now it's about a scrawny
uh developmentally like
uh um physically uh a weakling a
weakling born with a weak heart perhaps
like someone suffering from many
physical ailments who is so desperate to
fight for his country to help others
that he tries to cheat his way into the
military
and he is of of such strong heart he has
chosen for the super soldier program
so here's a guy of good moral character
standing and honor who wants to serve
his country fight against the bad guys
and sacrifice whatever it takes for his
community
he defends his friends by fighting in
the streets and then there's that scene
where he jumps on the grenade his
motivation is to sacrifice himself for
everyone else self-sacrifice
self-sacrifice Captain Marvel's
motivation was to benefit herself and to
be able to do whatever she wanted
Captain America
his his whole motivation is we don't we
don't trade lives we're not going to
sacrifice one for any his deontological
moralist Thanos is utilitarian Thanos
wants to kill half the universe save
half the life
Captain America says we don't trade
lives Captain Marvel Robs a guy in the
beginning of the in the movie he's he
says you should smile so she steals his
clothes and his motorcycle think about
that motivation that is the woke
feminist motivation of I can do whatever
I want then think about the other
character motivations Jude Law's
character says control your emotions and
then finally at the end she goes no and
that is her ultimate motivation the
story arc for her is she can do whatever
she wants because she's powerful and she
shouldn't have to listen to any man who
tells her to control herself Captain
America's motivation is I will die for
you so you can live a better life it is
the Hillary Clinton quote personified
when she said women are the real victims
of war because their husbands and their
brothers and their sons die that's
that's that exemplifies it perfectly
that's amazing self-sacrifice versus
self-validation that is the difference
between the way I was taught to write
and draw superheroes and the way
superheroes are being presented today
right there everything is a you know all
of these new superheroes that are coming
out of Marvel they're all selfie taking
self-aggrandizing narcissists eating
lunch and dinner together at diners
that's what they're doing there's no you
know my book cyber frog cyber frog says
in the in the very you know in the very
first couple of pages you know he just
says because people don't like him he's
ugly he's cyber frog so he says I've
found something to love about humans and
I'm willing to die for them you know and
that's that's the thing that's heroism
to me how many modern superheroes
are stories of young kids who wish they
had superpowers
modern ones not too many you don't think
so I'm not sure well maybe
um who are you thinking about I'm
thinking about the Captain Marvel uh uh
Miss Marvel Miss Marvel yeah right so
there's a story of like wow I've got two
powers and I'm gonna be an Avenger too
well that's me that's the meta nature of
Hollywood now that everything has to be
meta Shazam
uh no not not so not so much not so much
you don't think he wanted the the
Wizards Powers uh that he got he got
pulled in and brought into it it was
different I'm thinking about just like
I'm thinking about Miss Marvel
specifically and I was thinking about
Miles Morales you know in the in the
news into the spider verse he's like wow
I got spider powers too and then I was
thinking about growing up watching X-Men
and an X-Men typically the kids who got
powers were panicked and scared and and
didn't want it to happen and the parents
were freaking out and this the story
with you know early the X-Men stuff I
grew up on was it was actually bad to be
a mutant it was scary it was bad and
they weren't happy about it it was often
depicted as like your mutant Powers were
a curse not a gift and then Charles
Xavier would be like no no don't worry
like I'm gonna help you through this
nowadays the mentality among younger
people is more so like I want to give me
power give me power yeah
I felt like DC was all all maybe not
always but I didn't read a lot of DC but
it felt like DC was more
just about raw power and Marvel was
about psychological
stuff did you guys get that Vibe yeah I
mean do you see Comics I like DC better
aspirational Heroes Heroes to look up to
you know Heroes to feel hope they're
gonna save you see that's the thing I
love about Superman that they they
flopped with the new movies I mean when
you see Christopher Reeve
you know everything's gonna be okay you
know he like you're like oh Superman's
here finally I'm terrified of the Man of
Steel version of Superman from the Zack
Snyder movies can I just can I just
complain about the scene in Batman v
Superman where Batman is about to you
know kill Superman and then he's like
you're letting him kill Martha and then
Batman goes your mom's name is Martha my
mom's name is Martha too she actually
friends their mom by their name what
should have happened and I'll say it
every single time is that when Batman
had the spirit of Superman's neck what
would what would have made it work is
then Batman sang the famous line let
this be the day you never forget the day
I defeated you and then three they
should have just recreated that scene
and then he throws the spear away and he
says my intention was always to make
sure you knew you were not Invincible
not to actually kill you and then it
would be like damn that but instead he
was like my mom's name's Martha too
Wanna Be Friends I was like oh no yes
of kryptonite I could have made this far
stronger and killed you much easier if I
wanted to yeah it it should have been he
proved his point it was never because
Batman's not a murderer yeah he wouldn't
arbitrarily want to kill her man his
point was to make sure Superman knew he
wasn't a God you know instead
all this like my mother is your mother
we're brothers all this crap this like
nepotism is like European uh monarchies
they're all cousins like it's a bunch of
this crap it's like psychological
manipulation to make you think it is
some value if the guy's your brother
he's an idiot he's an idiot this is uh
what I was always told is that Marvel
was people trying to be heroes and DC
was Heroes trying to be people there you
go so like
I I noticed watching the Justice League
cartoons they always refer to each other
as their first given names Batman
doesn't call Superman Superman calls him
Clark calls him Bruce they refer to each
other as people but they are heroes and
then the interesting thing is Superman's
identity is Superman Kal-El and his
secret identity is Clark Kent whereas in
Marvel often it's like Peter Parker is
the person in the secret and secret
identity is or like his you know the
costume is Spider-Man whereas for
Superman the costume is Clark Kent who
are you guys favorite superhero of all
time
Superman
I just is the definitive hero I believe
Batman Batman you like Batman better
that's why I was really disappointed by
the movie uh I love the the uh comic fan
Trope of given enough time Batman can
defeat anyone I love God they called
that a DC they called it like yeah
Batman with enough planning but I feel
like Superman could kill Batman at any
time if he wanted to nope tonight yeah
but he blast them for morbid
technically I would say technically but
I guess the issue is there are a lot of
super powerful villains who are on par
with Superman that haven't been able to
take down Batman because the because
Batman is a figment of our imagination
what makes him a good character is his
ability to survive and overcome with no
superpowers that's why I like Batman
granted he's a very very rich dude you
know and he's able to buy this stuff
you know it is what it is the fantasy is
we could be Batman yep we can train
ourselves we could have enough money we
could be Batman yes the whole thing but
you can't you know fly you can't do
those things Batman's just a dude but
he's a martial artist he trains right he
eats right he gets beat up he gets
injured sometimes he gets back he gets
his back broken and he rises back up to
the challenge that's that's that's a
superhero man that's fantastic I mean
early early Batman was silly and they
made him really amazing throughout the
years I do I really love the the history
of how like the Golden Age of comics was
kind of hokey Superman could fire a
little Superman's from his hand did you
know that yeah it's what it makes no
sense you know whatever they invented
new powers all the time in this overage
whatever the Silver age the 80s no
Silver age was from like the 50s to the
70s I think the early 70s it was a
golden age before that golden age was
the like yeah the 1930s or late 30s to
the early 50s but I want to say the 80s
is when things I think got really mature
yeah and the writing got really good
um and then actually I think one of the
most profound moments in Comics but I
guess it's technically cartoons is the
uh Mr Freeze the story arc the
retconning of his history in the Batman
animated series I think the first
cartoon ever won an Emmy
and that was for I think that was was it
really that the first maybe not the
first time but one of the first times a
villain's story arc was sympathetic it
used to be all one-dimensional I'm gonna
rule the world I deserve power that's
what I love about the old Batman the
Animated Series it's actually super
anti-corporate all of them are just
generic corporate villains but Mr Freeze
was actually a fairly three-dimensional
character given the story with his wife
and that what wasn't clayface's story in
the animated series that he was a guy
who was negatively impacted by a
cosmetic product that turned him into a
monster there were a bunch of different
clay faces one was an actor you know I
think they're like five different clay
fish he was like people on a cosmetic
and then started his skin started to
melted man bat was great in that too man
bat was great yeah but uh it's Mr Freeze
right yes he was always one-dimensional
and then they made his story arc that
his wife was dying and he would stop at
nothing to save her life and then you're
like you feel bad because he's a bad guy
plus the delivery on all that dialogue
in that in that episode is so good yeah
you should do an arc where he gets an
honorary degree from Harvard and he's
like I'm Dr freeze now no you're not
it's not even a real degree I'm just
kidding now now it's gonna now I just
wait there's gonna be a comic that comes
out soon where Mr Freeze teams up with
Greta tunberg to reduce the difference
no that's why I brought it up
no please I look I hope they I hope they
keep producing this garbage and they
destroy themselves and then you know
your Comics all caps we're here comic
skates here to to step in and and you
know that's that's a good see we love
comic books I could talk about this all
day long I grew up with these
superheroes I love these superheroes
I've been a Creator I've worked on these
superheroes for uh most of my life now
but uh unfortunately the the way things
are at Marvel and DC they're
inhospitable remember what was that
super well comic they made with safe
space and it never came out
they never release them what is it what
is it the new Warriors yeah new new
Warriors I wonder if that was a joke
like I feel like that whole thing was uh
hopefully became one yeah it sure did
what a horrible concept look at this
okay for those days for those that don't
know you need to understand that the the
hugging brother and sister right there
brother and sister yeah Snowflake and
safe space in one of them they actually
described one of them they actually
describe as being a stereotypical jock
which I've never seen a stereotypical
jock with pink hair but that's just me
wait wait the best one is the door of
the Explorer Trailblazer is that is that
they call their chubby Inuit yeah who
had a backpack that she could pull
anything out of and the other one yeah
the Explorer and the other one is is uh
powered by internet gas yeah the
internet what were oh yeah that guy this
had to have been a joke it was a troll
it must have been it wasn't it
it's on the website introducing yeah
it's real I mean if they'd released it
people would have bought that that I
would have bought that this this is this
is an important story for for those that
are that don't understand the culture
War what happened in my opinion is that
Marvel started getting a bunch of emails
saying you need to do this and then
someone went to aboard me and said this
is what kids want you gotta sell a
product they'll buy and they went you're
right then they made it and they got
roasted they said we don't understand
they're emailing us saying they want
this because they don't realize it is a
it is a cult of annoying loud people and
they wasted tons of money and they're
destroying themselves by supporting this
but they don't buy it's not kids buying
these Comics right the the majority of
the the large-scale audience is still
men yeah
and that's the problem kids have moved
on to manga I mean the kids exactly
teenagers are buying mangana we lost two
generations from crappy story lines yeah
but I don't know maybe because it's
because manga story lines are are better
I I grew up on Batman and DC animated
serious Justice League and uh X-Men and
all that stuff and then it when it
started getting bad I just went straight
to to manga stuff where the story lines
were still good Dragon Ball Z I grew up
with that as well and so then as I'm
getting older and look I'm a big fan of
static shock but it was it was preachy
it was okay I liked the show but it was
very preachy then I see Naruto and the
only preaching in it is
you know try and save your enemies like
the the character Arc for Naruto is that
you might I absolutely love this writing
some of the best writing ever done have
you ever read or watched
so I'll I'll give you the the the the
the the very quick breakdown the best of
my abilities for those that aren't
familiar Naruto is about a world where
there are ninjas and they can use inner
energy called chakra to do you know I
guess you'd call them spells anyway
Naruto is an orphan his dad died
sacrificing himself to save their
Village uh Naruto finds a teacher a guy
named Uriah who's this legendary Ninja
I would call them techniques instead of
spells but they like to throw fireballs
and stuff yeah and they can like walk on
water and so anyway Naruto gets a
teacher he's this old creepy guy he's a
pervert he wrote several books
uh
he wrote these books because he was in
you know inspired throughout his life
Naruto eventually encounters a villain
in the story arc who goes by the name of
pain
and they fight and uh you find out that
this this guy Payne's real name is
nagato and he is a former uh pupil of
Jiraiya the same teacher Naruto now has
and then after this great battle
Naruto is like on the verge of defeating
this guy and then he says this famous
line of you know like I will save the
world or something like this you're like
I'm I'm gonna be the hero and and make
my enemies my friends and I'm gonna not
not allow the pain and it was a direct
quote
from Jiraiya his teacher who wrote this
book about a character and Jiraiya had
been quoting his pupil so basically what
happens is when drai is younger he
trains this kid whose idealistic wants
to save the world who says this
inspiring line as like a 13 year old
jirai is so moved by it he writes this
book which is you know he then teaches
Naruto and so I love this because the
villain is now facing down this younger
you know ninja who says his own quote
back to him realizing he's become the
villain he swore to fought and and
Naruto now embodies his past ideals and
ideology I'm like that was just
brilliant wow it was really really good
that's Jerusalem like I I can't do it
justice you have to read it but
basically he's like he says the line and
then the villain's like that's my quote
you're saying it to me like that's who I
used to be that that's what we're
supposed to be doing and we're supposed
to be teaching lessons like that in
comics we're not supposed to uh you know
be trying to uh instill politics or
ideology in anyone we're just supposed
to be teaching kids like basic morals
like that I how to be a hero
self-sacrifice put others before you yet
save the villain of course there's very
little of that like you mentioned
earlier with Captain Marvel that's the
funniest part about that is it's so
simple
but it's so simple to understand that uh
Captain America telling a story of cell
sacrifice and wanting to help his fellow
man and even the idea that you could
even tell a story now about an
idealistic person wanting to protect or
wanting to serve his country they
probably wouldn't even do that story
let's let's talk about the first big
three of Marvel Iron Man a military
industrialist who's selling weapons for
profit has a profound experience and
realizes his weapons are being sold to
both sides causing this conflict and
then says I'm not doing this anymore and
it destroys his company so he builds
himself a suit of armor taken to his own
hands and then he fights the
military-industrial complex warmonger
Iron Monger to stop it from happening
and then the company does better than
ever they do renewable energy pop like
that is an amazing Arc of a guy who had
everything thing and was this cocky
a-hole who still is for but he then
decides it's not worth it to be a part
of this problem Captain America scrawny
young guy wants to Surf his country we
should talk about the cultural victories
of the first Marvel movies are then Thor
an arrogant prince who has everything
gets his powers taken from him and comes
to realize humility I'm like these are
Great Character artists that's Stan Lee
but yeah I mean Stan Lee I mean those
are his stories you understand like uh
we don't have guys like that anymore you
want to know why Marvel is in the Rut
that it is it's because Stan Lee's gone
why is Disney the way it is Walt
Disney's gone why is Star Wars the way
it is George Lucas sold it I mean you
know there are rare creative Geniuses
that come along and they have the heart
uh and the the empathy to be able to
write stories that touch people in a in
a in a unique way uh and and and build
their childhoods and then when they
leave or they die Gerard Tolkien gone
than other people paralytically inherit
it and destroy it these are people who
are forged in the world surrounded by
War that's absolutely the lessons being
told now what we have are people who are
forged by gluttony oh yeah we were
talking about writing stories when we
were what they're owed when we were when
we were reviewing prey we were talking
about how nobody in this movie looks
like they've lived through anything
actually difficult in their entire life
nobody looks like they've lived in the
wilderness nobody looks like they've
ever had to hunt for any type of food in
their life right so people are trying to
write stories now from a world that they
just can't understand but Stan Lee was
he silverage did he was he around in the
early days yeah yeah Stan Lee was
interesting because uh World War II
veteran sorry World War II veteran uh
yeah he was around in the Golden Age too
but uh the Silver age he launched it he
really did launch the Silver age uh even
though before there was Flash and Green
Lantern Hal Jordan in this that really
launched the Silver age but Stanley was
so disgusted by the politics of comics
in 1950s with the comics code and the
way things had become so silly that he
just wanted to quit and he told his wife
I'm so inspired by this he told his wife
he wanted to quit and his wife said just
do one your way before you quit 1961's
Fantastic Four number one that's that
was him doing it his way launched the
Marvel Revolution that's when the Silver
age Stan Lee enlisted in 1942 after the
attack on Pearl Harbor what a guy what a
guy it's one of the things gone are the
days there there used to be dozens and
dozens of actors all who had served in
the military who had extensive military
whether through draft or because they
enlisted because they believed in that
country and as that generation of people
has died off you start seeing that less
and less of the stories less and less of
our country of our culture's empathy
towards its own country is gone we talk
about this every time an actor passes
away that was older right it's like they
were born at a time when there was a
relative amount of support for America
and they believed in their country and
they believed in in what it stood for
now I believe a lot of that has kind of
been manufactured in a lot of ways by
the media and that there's a lot of
problems there but you don't see that
anymore I think like Adam drivers like
the only one I can think of off the top
of my head that's a newer age actor that
served in the military and you just
don't see that and it's going to be it's
going to lead to even more anti-American
storytelling whether it's in comics or
in film and television you know you know
what's interesting about manga is that
there is a common trope
um Black Clover have you ever heard of
it no another really great show really
great manga um I've not uh I stopped
after a while but
in this world
everybody not everybody but many people
will get a magic grimoire and magic
abilities so one day a grimoire comes to
you and then you have your book of
spells and you can cast certain spells
and certain elements there's one kid who
really wants to be a a magic Knight and
work for the you know he wants to join
the service basically but he has no
magic powers so Unity does he works out
until he's so incredibly powerful that
when he's in these like when he's in the
trials to become you know a knight or
whatever he has no spells but he just
like they he's extremely powerful like
he jumps and the ground cracks and he
shoots in the air super fast and they're
like what when when they first see him
with no magic they're like what a
pathetic loser how could he even try and
bother but then he's so physically
powerful that he actually ends up
winning and then there's like an arc
where he a book does appear to him it's
an anti-magic book he does a sword and
all of his capabilities are basically
his physical ability to wield it there's
other arcs too like anti-magic and stuff
but the general idea was you can work
hard and if you do you can be a magic
Knight it's a rocky Story I mean it
works every single time it's tried just
a normal guy who's determined you know
he's an underdog the Underdog Story he
works his way up and through hard work
uh through diligence uh and through
faith all of these things he becomes a
hero and self-sacrifice you can tell
that story over and over and over again
he beats unbeatable odds uh you know
just out of sheer will and determination
nobody's ever going to get tired of that
you could tell that story with a million
different characters they're doing it in
Japan right now that's why they're
kicking our ass they're raising our kids
right I mean look I'm uh
I like it I think I think a lot of it is
really great not all of it some of it's
stupid you know nobody not everything is
perfect uh bleach for instance also very
very very good more of a uh reluctant
thrust into Adventure hero's journey uh
still great story great ideas you're not
getting beaten over the head with the
with the preaching yeah you know it
seems like I'm thinking about the age of
comics we have the Golden Age we have
the Silver age which ended like the 70s
is that about right yeah then the Bronze
Age was like you know the 70s through
the the 1980s people are saying what
this is today is called the Iron Age
that's funny a term it's getting worse
no no the Iron Age the Iron Age is is
really uh you know independent creators
rising up and taking over the culture
because we have no choice I would like
to see a diamond age uh if possible
we've got we're on the verge of graphene
anyway also remember a lot of those
characters and a lot of these amazing
stories were written at a time when
these were not major conglomerates that
were homogenizing their storytelling
down to the most basic safe and
inoffensive model that they could make
for people to watch so people were
willing to take risks with their
storytelling in a way that they're not
willing to do anymore or the ones that
are aren't getting jobs by these
corporate conglomerates that are selling
these major problems yeah let's talk
about taking risks Ethan because I want
to hear about cyber frog too what's the
story okay so cyber frog is the story of
uh an evasion an alien Swarm of hornets
that goes from world to world and just
takes over and destroys they're they're
the ultimate parasites uh they live in
the in these gigantic Hive ships that
are made of the desiccated and digested
flesh of a million alien races uh and
they're coming to Earth to make their
last stand and the oxygen-rich
atmosphere of Earth is going to allow
them to be strengthened and unbeatable
there's a world out there called
Fredonia that has survived this they're
the only world that was able able to
fend off the Vespa so we don't know how
yet but they get this idea to send an
agent with a secret power to planet
Earth that'll be able to fend off the
Vespas and stop them within this being
is the ability to push back the vespis
and destroy their Invasion uh that
person ends up being cyber frog through
a sheer accident he accidentally becomes
a frog and a machine cyber frog but he
still has the power to stop this
Invasion except that he fails the years
1998 Bill Clinton gives his speech
confessing that he lied to the American
people and right then August 16 1998 The
Invasion hits Bill Clinton's pulled away
from the cameras and the entire world is
swarmed by these hornets and and I don't
want to too much spoilers but just an
incentive I'm unlike page three and a
guy explodes yeah are they like I I
don't wanna yeah I also don't want to
spoil anything are they like
mechanical horn are they like no they're
they're they're alien Hornets they are
very large super intelligent uh Alien
Hornets that what they do is they chew
up human being they see humans as cattle
livestock they chew up human beings and
their bones with their saliva they can
make paper like hornets make nests they
paper over our cities with our own
bodies uh and they can change with their
saliva change our blood into honey to
feed their young first book's called
blood honey because of that uh so that's
the situation cyber frog is absolutely
obliterated in the first issue he uh has
to go into regenerative hibernation
wakes up in the year 2018 and the Vespas
have just dominated planet Earth
Humanity's been basically torn to like
90 of humans are gone 10 of them are
still around and hiding uh and that's
where Rec Planet picks up uh it is cyber
frog alone versus
the entire world so cyber Frog 2 wreck
Planet uh it is a hero's journey
um you know a cyber frog in that book
asks himself how he can make a change
like how do I begin to change this how
do I begin to fix this and you know uh
his best friend Heather Swain is living
in the woods she survived those 20 years
she has a daughter now uh who lost her
father and he just realizes that step
one is to try to take the frown off of
this little girl's face and try to make
her life better uh you know step in for
Dad and sort of you know uh make her
life happier and that's the first way
to kind of save Humanity uh this is
episode two of four is that right 204
but I'm gonna keep going yeah yeah the
next one's called red extermination I'm
launching that one uh on the fourth of
July Independence Day now now certainly
going independent and leaving the big
successful industry you you certainly
you're not making lots of money off of
this Venture I'd imagine first one made
1.2 million dollars the second one made
1.45 million dollars so it's actually
doing better it's doing great this is
crowdfunding and this is the wonderful
thing about it like you know the comic
book industry doesn't have any incentive
uh to make the comics that people want
because their parent companies are
paying for them we talk about that a lot
we're in the Pro the post-profit age for
a lot of these companies that especially
for Comics I think for like for Warner
Brothers It's a write-off like they
don't they don't know I guarantee you
zazlabs like we have a comics division
he's like you mean the written ones holy
crap they see their comics comics are
just sort of going to uh reflect the
political uh stances of their parent
companies and that's a reason to keep
them around for ESG purposes Etc et
cetera but we at Comic skate and comic
skate is basically
um the term that describes an
affiliation of comic book creators and
fans who are tired of woke in comics we
love comic books we're not going to
support uh the mainstream anymore with
our money we're going to make our own
comics and we're going to use social
media to promote these comics and
crowdfunding to be able to fund them now
I do want to say there are some really
funny spoofs of manga there's one called
wall might uh so are you familiar with
my hero Academia yeah yeah yeah so it's
Donald Trump as uh you know like the
main guy uh all might right it's called
wall might yeah I remember that there's
a couple of them other ones that are
really funny oh yeah the one punch man
spoof
I can't remember what y'all was we
haven't moved in the other room I don't
have to look at but they're really funny
I'm looking at um cyber Frog's first
appearance in 94 1994 and Hall of Heroes
so when I first uh started in comics
that was that was the whole thing now
the I did about 10 issues 12 issues of
cyber frog in the 1990s and then went to
work for DC so what's so wonderful about
this is the idea of bringing a character
that was created with enthusiasm in the
1990s it's very meta and trying to make
him work in 2018 in a world that's
infested with woke the vespis or the
woke you understand so you know you've
got a character who's used to existing
and thriving in a world of Deadpool and
the sarcasm and the ultra violence and
he wakes up in 2018 where the world has
been utterly taken over by these
creatures that disrespect everything
that Humanity built their Philadelphia
looks even worse now you can see it on
the first page of the book you can see
what Philadelphia open it up and look
next page
boom that's Philly
are you glad you left yes that's an
amazing art man that's crazy those
powers like jumping can he jump super
high uh yeah he could jump he's got a
tongue those are his natural abilities
but like the the whole thing is he's got
a uh his mother is a spaceship a living
spaceship who represents the internet
and when they're connected together he
can rapid evolve and change his body to
meet any threat so she's been taken out
by the Vespas he's offline through this
entire book and therefore he has to rely
on his natural ability so the Cyber
aspect is connected to the Mothership
that's correct yeah and of course that
represents the internet and
communication and all that stuff the
whole thing is I guess I guess the the
issue that I see with all of this is
if we make stuff because we like it
we're a bunch of old dudes how do we get
this stuff to younger people to inspire
them and share the ideas and ideology
that will make their lives better
I think you get through to the parents
and then they end up watching it with
their kids sitting on their lap I'm
seeing more of that I'm seeing a lot of
uh friends of mine who love old Comics
love old media who aren't they're not
watching new Star Trek with their kids
they're watching old Star Trek with
their kids
well hold on a second I I don't think
there's any reason to be really afraid
understand we have the internet yeah I
mean we have the internet that they
didn't have that in the 19 early 1990s
or anything like that I mean people were
dependent on these big corporations to
get their Comics out to people I have
I'm on your show right now I'm probably
people are buying cyber frog because I'm
telling them about it we have this mass
communication device where we can
potentially speak to seven billion
people there there shouldn't be any
reason to stop us there shouldn't be a
way to stop people gotta watch the Next
Generation with their kids yeah oh Star
Trek Next Gen yeah the best I think
that's Star Trek in my opinion I think
part of it also Ethan is that people
need to learn to uh the ones who want to
go out on their own are going to have to
understand there's gonna be more work
that you don't have the infrastructure
that's built up through these Mega like
these Mega corporations that do they do
the printing they do the packaging they
do all this stuff it's going to be more
work but you'll reap more of a reward
and you'll be able to keep the profits
because you own the IP yeah that's the
IP is of owning the IPS I own cyber frog
outright you know which is the first
thing that I've actually owned entirely
by myself which is great it is a lot of
work
I was gonna say we uh we've been we
talked about this like a year ago that
we wanted to launch some kind of comic
or Manga style portal for timcast.com
and I've talked to a few people and the
challenge is the amount of work that
goes in like you said how many years did
it take to make this two years to make
that one year to fund it and in the in
between we made action figures and a
bunch of other stuff as well like in
order to actually make a
subscription-based like weekly thing is
a tremendous undertaking like what do
you how many people would you need to
put something together
on myself I might be able to write it
but it's not it's not the production
it's the Fulfillment because we're not
in or you know we don't have the direct
Market cyber frog isn't in comic book
stores if you want to buy cyber frog you
can look on Google look up cyber frog
dark Harvest that's the next book on in
the gogo you can back it there
um you know we we basically have to ship
everything by hand but the great thing
about crowdfunding is there's no real
possibility of loss you know
um how many issues that you're going to
need to make you know how much money you
have to spend I knew I had 1.5 billion
dollars to spend I was able to make PVC
toys to give away for free trading cards
bonus Comics that came with that for
like 25 is the lowest level to back at
and the book looks like that you don't
see Comics like that anymore yeah it's
like a weekend kick their asses are you
guys is there like a universe of Heroes
um yeah there's going to be I'm building
it out I'm building it out cyber frog
can't do it alone psychic gorilla from
space that's too close to the real
garage yeah uh I think it is like the
people that are going to be successful
are going to be the ones that are
business-minded and a lot of them I
think the ones that might be working
that are they feel attached to DC Marvel
even IDW is like they feel like they
need to stay there because they need the
infrastructure and they don't but
they're just going to have to put in the
work and another part of it is like
you've had to become your own
promotional arm a lot of them might not
want to be doing live streams might not
want to be out there promoting their
stuff so they feel like they're stuck at
these companies because they don't know
how to do the promotional state is meant
to do Comics you've got loud Mouse like
me and I'll go I'll come over Tim will
be nice enough to let me come on the
show and talk comic skate Comics gate
comicsgate.org go to that website you'll
see a bunch of other creators who have
similar stories uh yeah we have to
promote each other we have to do this as
a group we can't do it as individuals
and uh hashtag comicscape what's the
biggest difference in like your daily
activities since you've left the big
companies started your own
what does a day look like as opposed to
what it used to look like when you're
working I wake up in the morning I put
together 200 packages of that book I
ship them to the uh through UPS then I
start drawing and writing and then at
night usually around eight seven or
eight I do this I live stream and
promote people what was it like before
when you were at DC nothing but drawing
you know I would just draw and I scan my
pages and turn them in it's a much
bigger job I mean you know running your
own business obviously is way different
do you ever draw live yeah and like do
you ever do like time lapses where it's
like Zao and then I have I just I don't
want to bore people I'd rather people
just get the experience the fact that
I'm drawing is not that interesting it's
the final result to me I want you to
enter the world I want you I want to
take you to an annihilated Philadelphia
I want you to visit the Pine Barrens in
New Jersey we could go to an annihilated
Philadelphia right now only a couple
hours drive it's really close I want you
to go to the Pine Barons and live with
these raggedy Survivor I want you to see
cyber frog represents everybody he's not
black he's not white he's not he's
definitely not gay uh he's just a frog
and that means he represents everyone I
want you to see yourself in him because
he he has you know uh emotions feelings
uh you know um Ambitions and he makes
mistakes he's not perfect he's made a
terrible mistake and the fact that he
failed in 1998 and the world has
suffered for it
someone someone mentioned that Deep
Space Nine is better than the Next
Generation I just want to say actually I
agree
Star Trek at all oh really me and you
man me and you're the only ones in this
world what do you guys don't like it it
must be difficult being so wrong you
know what is it what is your biggest
problem with Star Wars or Star Trek Star
Trek I don't know I just find it I don't
want to say I don't want to you know get
into it too much because I'm sure some
trekkies are watching right now
in these in this world there are things
you're just not allowed to dislike and
that's it's one of the funniest things
about it like you can say like I don't
like this like you're you're wrong okay
I'm standing up straight and yelling at
each other face to face that's Star Trek
whereas Star Wars is like running and
Blasting and like Wookies screaming and
stuff Star Wars is dumb I am however
kind of excited to see that Picard
season three is actually picking up the
story for once my problem with Star Trek
is that you get Deep Space Nine and
you're like wow this is incredible and
then they're like okay for the next 15
years prequels and no story development
and I'm like I'm out the problem is
three seasons in right like you're like
I I love the people who are dude you
gotta watch the show by the third season
it's fantastic I'm like dude they get
one episode you get one like I I have
the the worst ADHD I shuffle between
seven and eight shows at a time where I
can maybe get through two to three
episodes at a time before my brain needs
to put something else on if you can't
hook me to your show in one episode you
get no more from me and real quick sorry
just one thing that bums me out is pick
hard
is finally picking up after like the
latest developments in the Star Trek
universe but it's all remember Diana
Troy remember Commander Riker that's
like the whole world
this is the problem with all of these
creators who didn't realize what was
going to happen when they sold their
Creations to these Mega corporations 50
60 years ago right they didn't realize
that some dude in an office who doesn't
have a creative bone in his body was not
going to see it as something that's
beautiful and artistic and something
that elicits human emotion they just
look at it as a way to look at
somebody's gonna make memes about this
look somebody's going to be able to sell
this on social media it happens in in in
short time frames as well you take a
look at the first Pirates of the
Caribbean how did they do so well
Pirates one is an amazing movie just a
sequel that's a sequelitis but but like
the famous line you best start believing
in Ghost Stories you're in one it's like
memeable it's like wow the ending where
he shoots
um Jeffrey rush and then he's like after
all these years you waste your shot and
goes and then will turns like he didn't
waste it and he drops it and then he
turns and dies masterful and then they
went okay now we'll take the iconography
we will jam it into a sequel extend the
play and do it 10 times they also turned
it into theme parks which became a big
part it was a theme park first it's uh
it's a bit oh yeah oh no you're right
but like um for a lot of this stuff it's
it's because it cross promotes into toys
it cross promotes into other mediums
that they use Johnny Depp Jack Sparrow
wasn't supposed to be all crazy yeah and
then Johnny Depp decided to make him
like listen here and it worked really
well he still goes to hospitals in in
uniform as as Captain Jack Sparrow to
visit kids in cancer Awards the first
movie was really well done and it was
just like the lore it was really
interesting then the second movie was
garbage that made no sense because they
just want to profit off of it well look
at third the same four they just I think
I think what was the dead men tell no
Tales yeah I think that one was actually
decent it was like the only other good
one look what they could have done like
JK Rowling ruined Harry Potter on her
own she owns everything like she she got
the last great publishing deal where
after those movies were those books were
so successful she has almost full
creative control over everything she
does right but she ended up just ruining
herself by being a major feminist I'm
imagining she's just like sitting in a
room like with her eyes half closed and
she's like oh uh
Dumbledore yeah he's gay
Potter's always a feminist so that's
Hermione Granger yeah you know what I
thought would be a cool tactic for uh a
movie or a comic and I'm gonna say it
publicly someone might create it is uh
if if the episode follows a piece of an
item and then it's all the people that
pick up the item and get killed with it
and then the item Falls and someone else
gets the item that's actually been done
I don't know what the original uh story
is but I know that American Dad spoofed
it with uh Roger the Alien will you
explain it better like there's a like I
say there's a gun and everyone the the
comic book is about the gun itself and
the people that carry it are kind of in
uh secondary yeah but it's about the the
weapon or the item like the data Cube or
whatever so watch American Dad
uh Roger takes a dump and it's gold gold
poop encrusted with jewels and then
there's an arc periodically throughout
the seasons of American Dad that follows
the item and the people around us and so
it's like some a janitor's cleaning and
he's like what's this and he finds it
and then his friend goes he's like he's
like hey Mike what'd you find there
what you got and he's like uh nothing
and he goes let me see it let me see it
and then he clubs him and takes it he
goes it's mine and then he runs and he
gets in his car then later on abruptly
It'll like pan away from Stan and then
show the truck driving on the road turns
widescreen the music gets eerie and then
it shows him driving to like a mountain
to like bury it yeah it's good because
you can just follow it that's been I
think the X-Files did something along
that lines where something keeps going
through pawn shops uh and it ends up
turning whoever buys it evil what I like
about it is it shows the main characters
as secondary characters and you get to
see how they react to the world rather
than how they create the world like if
you did that to the X-Men and there was
an item and you just watched each X-Men
deal with the item you'd get like
another perspective on the person the
best the best recurring characters in
television are actually designed to do
that a good recurring character in
movies and uh well not not movies but
intelligent is designed to take a main
character that you ex that you see exist
only within the realm of one universe
and they have the same interactions with
the same people all the time because the
world requires it a good guest like a
guest character or recurring character
who lives in a world outside of what
they experience every day is supposed to
draw out different performances from
those characters so you see a different
side of them we are going to go to super
chats so if you have you have already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends and I guess right
now our big thing that we're trying to
promote is head over to trash house
records and purchase the song bright
eyes that we just released as of today
until next Thursday that is the time
period we have to sell as many songs as
possible so that we can try and once
again chart on Billboard and then
basically give a big middle finger to
all of these companies that are trying
to put their boot on us because they
don't like the fact that we're pushing
back and developing culture so uh if we
can get a decent amount I think we only
need like 10 000 sales because that's
like a big number you know in one week
but uh if you want to support our work
to say do it let's read what you got all
right
Dirty Jimmy says the pace of repression
outstrips our ability to understand it
if you know then you know
I've been actually feeling kind of uh
mixed a little bit sometimes confident
the fact that the conversations we've
been able to have have been expanding
the calling out of the lies calling out
fauci calling uh we just saw the
international sports League banned males
and women's sports which was massive I
feel like we're actually gaining a lot
of ground yeah I mean look if you look
at the success of uh Ethan's comic a
million dollars you're outside of the
the big machine and you're more
successful so it's almost like
like the independent decentralization is
actually winning and the cult is being
pushed back Ethan and Eric July are
probably the our two fantastic examples
of people that are proving that it can
be done on your own are you working with
Eric uh
uh um uh anyway uh you know listen uh
yeah it just goes to show you know if
you if you listen to the fans and you're
paying attention to the fans you're
going to make money that's that's what
we'd like to impart the Marvel hilarious
that that's like hard to explain to
people now that don't understand that
listening to the fans is actually just a
great way to make that what happens is
people are getting confused by the loud
minority and they think that's the fan
base but so it's a little bit of a
diffusion essay federality says Tim you
and Bill's announcement today was epic
he's like Jack's benevolent twin and
you're becoming better than Cronkite
every day walk to Walk The Walk dudes
also thank you
check out youtube.com timcast and the
latest episode of the culture War
podcast where we basically announced
we're suing California and then we're
that's like actually happening it's like
the paper like they handy the paperwork
I signed some papers
um
as for band camp we are beginning the
preliminary
exploratory options of how we take legal
action uh someone I saw several super
chats from people saying that they do
not have access to the song they
purchased which would mean something
weird happened I mean you bought a songs
in their platform and then they took
that song away from you so did they
steal it
do they do they owe you the money I
don't have access to any of those people
I don't know their emails I don't know
who they are I don't know who lost it I
don't know how to get in contact with
them so
this seems like a contract violation
between the user and me from like
bandcamp should be liable for this this
used to happen a lot on iTunes and stuff
right you'd buy a movie and it would be
on the server and then when rights would
be renegotiated and the movie would be
taken off that platform you suddenly
don't have access to the movie you
purchased anymore and you don't know
whether they're going to be quiet or not
you always buy physical media exactly
Shane H Wilder says love seeing you and
Tom taking over the charts keep it going
rock on guys and peace be with all of
you I will say uh
when we release the other songs
I was we did a heavy promotion Friday
Saturday and Sunday
and I think we're getting to the point
where the music thing needs to just
become its own entity and be responsible
more for itself which is what I'm I'm
basically saying is I won't be promoting
it as heavily though we will still do
like promo shout out please buy it
throughout the next week of episodes we
got to get to the point where we just
start putting out music and let the
machine build itself and the Snowballs
roll down the hill so we can't treat
every song like the biggest release ever
we can't just try and Hyper Focus every
single one no we put out this song we've
been sitting on it for a year we'll put
another song next month and we'll just
let the music be the music and then
exist as its library and then hopefully
the snowball rolls down the hill
but more importantly we also need to
spread the resources around to start
just producing more music from other
artists
all right let's see
memuru says Ian please come back to us
what happened to Tim isn't your fault
the real Tim would want you to move on
not spend all of your time in the
metaverse reliving Tim cast episodes
from 20 years ago that's a message from
the future thank you
all right
John Curson says some bangers dropped
today with bright eyes and Dr James
Lindsay workshop on inclusion both left
me speechless like Brandon Caserta's
story on Being Framed by the FBI haha
felt smothered by memes
James Dean just said I requested a
refund from bandcamp no response well
see here's the issue
if you request a refund from them but
they've deleted my account I don't know
where they get the money from they've
not contacted me so we got a problem
guys I don't have a list of the people
who need a refund
I have no idea I'm looking at it you go
to timcast.bandcamp.com it's it's blank
it just shows your name then you go to
the Wayback machine and it shows only
ever wanted yup it's nasty well so
there's 10 cent are you so in 10 cent
like are you gonna sue the owners are
epic games which owns bandcamp bandcamp
is an entity and they're based on North
Carolina I guess so it's going to be
really interesting
um but I we're like I got you know
whatever
um I hope they they should expect it and
I don't I don't know how far this goes
but
they try to do this thing these tech
companies where they're like you must go
to arbitration and I'm like that's for a
judge to decide like if we file and a
judge says an arbitration clause about
arbitration I'll say okay but the judge
might be alike no dice like this is this
is it's up to the judge so my attitude
is simply I feel wronged I think all the
people who purchased the song from
bandcamp which is Thousands were wronged
and we may be dealing with something
like five to ten thousand arbitration
claims
I mean for the people who here's what
you got to understand it's not just the
song it's that if you were on that page
you could comment and see other fans of
the song you weren't just buying the
song you were using the platform to gain
access to a community
that's what you were paying for and
they've taken it away from you and
Bryson gray he was unceremoniously
removed and five times August
yep
Harpy says checked bandcamp and no
longer have access to song
all right well here's the thing I never
revoked that license from you I say that
you if you bought it you have a right to
listen to that song whenever you want
bandcamp took it from you it sounds like
there's a lawsuit sounds like some kind
of theft or something I don't know like
if you went to Best Buy and bought a CD
and then and then you're like I have a
right to listen to Metallica and then a
guy from Best Buy showed up your house
and took the CD from you like that'd be
like a weird thing you know what I mean
and it's like well look the CD was ours
you bought a license to it it's like
hold on there a minute no
the license was from them I just went to
your store to buy it yeah well you know
I don't know I think it's weird at the
very least I don't understand how this
will uh
how this will affect the future of
Commerce and thus there's some kind of
precedent that needs to be explored
because obviously Best Buy couldn't send
an employee to take a CD from your house
that is your copy of the CD you know you
don't own the music you own the right to
that copy of the music to listen to
there are certain restrictions on how
you can distribute or play it especially
if you're a business
but I'm like
it it's it's it's it's
I don't know and Technology changes so
fast the the law and president never
catch up let's let's try it this way
imagine you bought a ticket to see a
movie at a theater
and then when you shut up the theater
the movie just didn't play anything yeah
you'd be like hey dude I bought a ticket
for this movie and then when we banned
the movie it's like well I bought the
ticket from you dude yeah I don't know
like the money for the movie theaters
goes to the goes to Hollywood right and
the theater 60 60 to Hollywood 40 the
theater gets a cut just like band camp
takes a cut yeah so imagine going to the
movies and buying a ticket and then
sitting down in the movie Never plays
yeah and they say well we banned the
movie from the theater it's like well
then you owe me my money back and they
go I get out you're banned any chance
that you would put a CD out
not a CD a vinyl maybe vinyl yeah this
is like what we talk about a lot like
when you try to call up these tech
companies like if you have an issue with
Facebook do you actually get on the
phone with Facebook and talk to them no
they just assume that your problem that
you're just not going to want to deal
with the vast bureaucracy
bureaucracy and the inability to get a
hold of someone and actually take care
of these issues so they end up winning
either way you know big problem here too
uh they got bought bandcamp got bought
March 2nd of 2022 by epic games it was
March 17th two weeks later of 2022 they
changed their terms of service so get a
copy of the terms before the sale and
then put that up against the terms now
and see what they change and see if it's
legal to do that well it's a customer
that's signed under the old terms
yeah but probably what happened is they
sent out an email saying the terms have
been updated you know what I mean yeah
which is terms don't matter people don't
understand judges aren't robots who are
like let me see here ah the code script
reads if this then that sorry have a
nice day they're human beings and if
someone comes in and says your honor our
terms say that we can take all of your
money whenever we want he's going to be
like shut up
can't do that it's crazy to me I talk to
so many people and maybe this is
something for people who don't
understand how business operates and
they've not run a company but they'll be
like well if you had a contract then you
have to do it I'm like that doesn't mean
anything
I can go ask a judge like so people seem
to think that if I if I say like hey
let's do a deal Ethan where you know I
will uh distribute the comics and for
every comic I sell I get a percentage
cut just sign this document and then you
say you got a buddy and you sign it and
the document actually says I hereby
revoke you know we're send Give All
rights to dim pool he owns it 100
that would not fly in court
you'd go to you'd go to court and I'd be
like he agreed to give me the full the
full ownership of all of his IP and then
he would just say to the judge that's
not what we agreed upon and that's
insane I would never have signed that
and then the judge would be like why
didn't you read and be like I did I
misunderstood it the judge will be like
okay the contract is voided like a judge
can simply be like no reasonable person
would actually agree to what you're
talking about you were trying to exploit
someone the contract is avoided I hereby
rule bang gavel people think judges are
like but there's a contract and you
signed it sorry now if it was something
more reasonable like
I said I'll give you I'll take five
percent but the contract says 20. now
you're in trouble because you're getting
back I never agreed to 20 I'm like well
you signed 20. like now you you might be
lying to me but to for something so
absurd so if in their terms it's
something like you to have no you you
can't sue us a judge might be like get
out of here they can sue you I I I'm
letting it go or they might say no
depends on what the judge wants to do
sometimes judges do get real rigid and
just say I'm Bound by you know statutory
law or whatever
but sometimes you get good or bad judges
that's why there's an appeals process
all right
Fatboy says you have no clue about Tick
Tock apparently I've been on there two
years and have never seen China
influence I did however learn more about
what happened in Ohio and all the
chemical food pressing plants blown up
Etc news that is it don't you get it you
don't see the influence that's the point
but showing you chemical and food
processing plant explosions to make you
think that there is something some inner
turmoil in this country is a part of
their attempt in my opinion to sow
Discord you look at it's not about a
video popping up being like China is
great you love China it's a video that
pops up that says you should sterilize
your children and other people sing
videos saying your country is falling
apart and everything's burning down
quick run
that's the attack on your psyche if
they're showing you tons of chemical
food plants and explosions that is that
is literally it right I talked about
this with all the food plants burning
down
they happen all the time
and everyone kept saying look at all
these you see all the stories about
train derailments we didn't talk about
it because people are people like
because it's not news
East Palestine was news a major chemical
spill explosion they burned it off then
all of a sudden everyone started saying
look at all these trained derailments
that are happening all over the country
and then I looked it up and I'm like
yeah that's actually par for the course
oh yeah there's like a thousand like
there's 1700 per year on average a lot
yeah so we're talking about more than
100 per month that happened but because
of East Palestine media Outlets were
like let's keep showing these over and
over and over again because it gets
clicks and I'm like it's not news that
these things happen so much of our Lives
now is algorithmically manipulated
because so much of your life takes place
looking into your phone almost all the
time when you really think about how
often you look at your phone on a daily
basis you really are at the whims of
what your phone is showing you and
whether that's Instagram YouTube Tick
Tock any of these places your mood your
state of mind can ultimately be
controlled by your phone just the
radiation coming off the screen I think
we were just telling the other day I was
like dude have there been any long-term
studies that tell us that these things
aren't going to Nuke our brains in 50
years
does that exist I don't know with the
Ethan do you write on a like a Wacom
digital tablet or do you write on paper
no I write on paper yeah do you feel
freed from the algorithm when you're
working
I just for me it's a tactile experience
that I really need to touch paper and a
pen and actually feel the drag of the
pen I can't really put that into words
but it's how I've always drawn and I'm
not looking to to change that in any way
um I see Wacom tablets and everything
don't hate me for those fellow artists I
see it as cheating I mean it really is
like you get one shot at it and you can
use white out and everything like that
but when you can just blow up this part
and move this around it doesn't feel
it's like the digitization of music yeah
it just feels a little artificial to me
but no judgment you know people do their
thing I'm old-fashioned
all right what do we got here son of a
Murph says is that a Novo guitar hanging
behind you had the chance to play one
today and they're freaking sweet enjoy
the weekend everyone no it's a Harmony
silhouette beautiful machine yeah it's
actually one of my favorites my my Strat
the one that I'm the Strat that I'm
playing in the bright eyes music video
is my favorite guitar followed by that
one that's it's amazing sounds so good I
love it
good good play good action so good
G fazer says I said this on Stick sex
and Hammer if Tick Tock gets banned Elon
needs to jump on this with his own
version or better yet bring back Vine
seriously Tick Tock is Vine essentially
Elon bring back Vine bring back Vine and
Tick Tock is is done we've got to worry
about it I wonder Vine was it costing
the money for hosting no they wanted
people to use Twitter instead they
wanted people to post the same things
they were posting but on Twitter but
that's not how it works remember
Periscope oh yeah that was Twitter's
video yeah and then it yeah
well Tick Tock started as like a karaoke
app right it's started as like it was
just something called musically I
believe so yeah and so I'm wondering if
that was by Design or if they just
stumbled across something like oh my God
we control 150 million Americans like
Let's do let's do something with this
this is a powerful tools they're real
look at the comments on Tick Tock posts
and I'm like I don't think that's real
people we were talking about that
because they did the we were looking at
the Gotham Knights reviews and all of
the it's got like an 18 from critics and
if the critics hate it it means it's
either really really good or even worse
than you could possibly in this case
it's worse than you could possibly
imagine but most of the comments for the
positive ones all look extremely fake
because the audience score was like 53
and it's like it's all the most generic
stuff you've ever seen and most of them
they either have egg you know egg
avatars they don't have actual pictures
there no way to know we gotta snag that
duet functionality if we want to make
something as good as Tick Tock because
being able to video respond to someone
in the videos tell Bill to do it on
mines yeah they'll make make a a video
shorts app that Rivals what Tick Tock is
you know if mines is about to build out
a sweet video app that's the way to do
it in band dancing videos no dancing
videos and then we'll we'll keep the
kids serious
I like the dancing videos oh hey I love
the dancing piece no I was talking about
you know when you talked a couple weeks
ago about the girl dancing in the in
like the Sam's Club uh you talked about
it on the channel That girl went on to
be like she has like three million
followers now and she does like
choreography for like Shania Twain and
built an entire like ridiculous career
because she used to record those videos
but that's the way it started Adrian
Curry says thank God Stanley left us
before women destroyed nerdum Comic Con
E3 DC Marvel and not Lord of the Rings
all lost to us because of feminism not
only did Stan leave us he built
Stanley's superhumans one of the
greatest shows on television before he
left us and it's a masterpiece hey I
don't by the way I want to just I don't
think women destroyed nardim I think
feminism did and I think you know woke
destroyed nerdum I mean we had we've had
females who understand that mostly you
know when you're writing Daredevil
you're writing it for boys uh and they
understand that and they do a great job
so women you're welcome in comics but
understand 95 of your audience is male
it's just knowing that in mind this is
an attack on masculinity they hate it
that's right like during gamergate the
big thing was they want to make walking
simulators they're like why are games
always predicated on violence and it's
like
have you played the new Harry Potter
game no it's like it's Harry Potter but
there's combat in it and it's funny
because there's substantially more
combat than Harry Potter had in its
whole story yeah like granted there were
big battles in Harry Potter but later on
for the most part it was like solving
puzzles because that was the structure
of the story right it made sense for the
bat the battles to happen later on and
there is good feminists there is good
feminist media I will always push people
to Buffy the Vampire Slayer if you want
to watch actual good feminist television
with a feminist character that actually
exists in the world where she has
emotions she's a fully fledged person
and she is not somebody that just beats
up a bunch of men and makes a bunch of
quips she's actually vulnerable go watch
bunker games yes no go to if you want to
get a calm Escape project by a
completely based woman Irene strakowski
left Marvel Comics of her own accord to
come be calm Escape just out of a moral
sense she's got a book called fiendish 2
on Indiegogo right now I promise you it
is amazing you will love it go back
fiendish to Indiegogo what if we find a
way to team up and we can help
distribute the stuff through our website
Tim are you that good of a guy are you
an angel from heaven
I'm saying like we we keep talking about
how like
the what the number one thing we do
outside of talking politics is trying to
build culture
so I've said this before look I could
hire 10 more conservative commentators
libertarian commentators expected
liberals and just be talk radio or we
can try and win a culture War the daily
wire does that and they do it very well
they they've they've they've got a great
they've done a great job of finding
personalities who who are in this space
of the freedom faction to talk about
these ideas they've also done big
cultural endeavors
my thing is like I'm gonna Focus
strictly on the cultural stuff and try
and just build that kind of stuff so if
there was a way that we could create
some kind of portal or some kind of Hub
on timcast.com
that like I was mentioning before we
wanted to do some kind of like weekly
chapter release or something you know
maybe there's a way to do it Shonen Jump
style were you talking about like
digital release yeah like because Amazon
did comixology right and then they the
the infrastructure for it was like
really hard to upkeep from what I
understand Ethan do you know anything
about that like uh comixology which was
bought by Amazon right yeah yeah they
they destroyed the technology and made
it really practical and hard to use
here's what I'm thinking
I I I'd have to know what you guys are
working with and what you guys need but
my idea is like if we had a way to do
like I wanted to do weekly chapters of
comics kind of like how Shonen Jump
they'd put their release out and then
you have like chapters every week the
new Naruto would come out and I would
read it but if it's too hard to do one
chapter of a comic every week is what
people said it could be like one chapter
every other week and you interlace them
so if it takes someone two weeks to do a
chapter then you know you put that up
and then two weeks later the next one
goes up and then in between you're
you're skipping out or maybe even three
weeks or something like that some way to
have like hey this Wednesday is the
latest release of the chapter of
whatever we have to create stories this
is the thing I mean you know comic books
are easy an easy way to put stories out
there and the problem is right now the
left has complete domination woke has
all of the storytelling that Americans
at the West are feeding to their kids
and our kids are hungry for they're
going to Japan for their needs we really
do need a way to get our stories out
there to more people uh this non-woke
stuff that I would love to talk to about
this uh we got uh dushida says Superman
can beat Goku Batman proved he can beat
Superman therefore Batman is greater
than Goku and everyone that Goku
defeated Batman is the greatest
superhero let me just pause and say it
is there's no that you don't need to do
that Batman can defeat Goku and it's not
even an argument okay look if you're
gonna be like who would win in a fight
Batman or Thanos or Batman or name
character you know eternity and it's
like well here's what Batman would do no
no no Batman vs Goku is no question no
argument Batman is a ninja he has
stealth he is tactical Goku is overly
trusting it is in Goku's character Arc
to be extremely trusting and get taken
advantage of Batman would walk up to
Goku and then do a single move that
would incapacitate Goku he'd like Nerf
pinch him and Goku would just like fall
asleep
because Batman would trust him he'd be
like I have no reason to fight you
Batman you're a good guy and then Batman
will go and then Goku
yeah
Superman would kill Batman nope blast
him with heat Rays from space
Superman's a good guy so he wouldn't do
that that's the point of the the debate
it's like having the Deathstroke versus
Deadpool debate that everyone always
says there's the guy who did the video
Arena no end of it yeah but look look so
you could you could say I I personally
believe it would be a deus ex machina
for you to say Superman
could heat blast and kill Batman because
Batman's superpower is actually his
ability to escape and solve problems so
it's like
I I've heard it described as Peak human
as the way to describe it it wouldn't
make sense for Batman's character to
instantly be taken out by Superman yeah
he'd be ready for it he thinks ahead
right he wouldn't always be ready for it
I mean he'd have to have kryptonite on
his he doesn't and Superman does it
always yep oh my God what a jerk yeah
well and and then that's a hard World
there was this there was the the Justice
League Arc where all of the superheroes
weaknesses are being used against him
someone stole Batman's counter plans and
started executing him against the heroes
and then they find out they're like you
drafted these strategies to take us all
down in this contract yeah I think
that's what it was and then Batman's
like yes he just says yeah it's the best
part of that is I mean he says they all
get offended that he that he has all the
list of how to defeat them all and
they're they're also perfect he's like
I'm not offended he's like you're you're
basically like weapons of mass
destruction you want me to do yeah yeah
I think Bradley Cooper from Limitless
could be Batman on the Limitless pill oh
which means I to do my Daily Show watch
the Limitless TV show which is one of
the very few examples of a television
show that should not be good but
absolutely really got one season and
then they killed it the movie was so
dumb he's like this pill's making Super
Start forgot to pay my bookie like what
I guess the show is great it's got
Jennifer Carpenter from Dexter purple
says Black cover Naruto Dragon Ball you
like all my favorite manga you can
finish Black cover clover in manga still
going you need to check out one piece
and one punch man also Attack on Titan
one punch man is so good it is so good
it in fact it was so good it actually
broke into American mainstream and it
was like Vice was writing how good it
was fantastic uh one piece I've heard
tremendously great things about never
got into it though an attack on Titan is
a masterpiece
seriously if you are involved in culture
War politics you really need to watch
Attack on Titan it is like there's that
joke where Jordan Peterson says to watch
it but I'm like I'm pretty sure he would
tell you to watch it if he if he did
because it's a it's about privilege and
like it it covers like woke politics and
post-modernism it is brilliant you're
familiar with Attack on Titan uh I've
seen it yeah but I've not read it again
I'm uh you know manga is kind of I've
only barely uh scratched the surface of
manga all right we'll grab uh we'll grab
one more what do you got Jasper plan
nine says I'm new here Tim is winning me
over with his promoting a parallel
economy cheers panel that's what we are
trying to do so head over to
trashouserecords.com by bright eyes so
we can start creating these we are but a
humble acorn in the ground we are not a
a massive oak tree or anything like that
maybe 10 20 years maybe in a hundred
years there will be a massive TMG big
parent media corporation that has
American values and and believes in the
family and meritocracy and individualism
for today we are but a a few humble
shows but if we win and we keep winning
here's what you gotta understand
three of three songs hit billboard I am
telling you there are people out there
who wish they were a musician or rock
stars who wish they could get their song
charting and they're like how do I do it
man right now many of these people are
working for woke record labels or signed
to them and they're being told do as
you're told takes the take the vax kick
out your band members who vote for Trump
otherwise you will never make it and
they're going I wish I didn't have to
but I have no choice then off the
distance they look and they're like that
dude on his own got all three of his
songs on Billboard what am I doing with
these guys we want to steal them all we
want people who are in that woke machine
to be like there's clearly a way to do
this because that guy's more successful
than we've ever been and we're sitting
here bending the need of these crackpots
and he would never make us do that
that's why I'm like we gotta win now
here's what I think we we can't just
keep doing like here's another one of
Tim pool songs which is why we're like
we need to expand but it's like we
started pushing a snowball down the hill
I think the fact that we got three of
three on Billboard gives us is a
tremendous launching pad to be able to
go to people and be like don't do those
deals they can't get it done for you
start working with us we will plant
those seeds and your song will be more
successful with us than with anybody
else then you'll start seeing these
people be like I'd sign with you man but
I'm not confident you're actually gonna
get my song out there we're going to do
a deal you're gonna forget about the
music if I go do a deal with Tim Poole
I'm going to be on Billboard my my debut
release is going to be a hit and I'm and
it's going to be top of iTunes and
they're going to be like no wait don't
be woke and they're gonna be like nah
I'm okay we need the freedom faction to
have these cultural tools I don't care
if it's me or anybody else who's doing
it Comics Gates clearly doing it support
Comics gate thank you so this is when
you say hi comic skate High Comics gate
this is what we need to do that's the
thing we need people who work at Marvel
in DC to stand up and say you know what
I don't want to do this anymore it's not
doesn't make me feel good and then go
independent and win so with your support
we will become a member at timcast.com
to get access to our Discord our hangout
where we share a lot of this cultural
stuff and and you know
um beta testing we're working on
basically giving people in the elite
club Early Access and then people in the
VIP chat room access to our call-in show
so uh become a member supporter work if
you really do believe in it and you want
to help us out the time is now there's
not much time left we've got we've got
to be active so I really do appreciate
your support you can follow the show at
timcast.com you can follow me personally
at timcast uh Ethan you want to shout
anything out yeah I'd like to shout out
John malin's Godlike on Indiegogo I'd
like to shout out Shane Davis's and
glorious Rex 2 on Indiegogo and of
course cyber frog dark Harvest uh on
Indiegogo if you'd like to buy any of
the old cyber frog stuff you can find it
on eBay just search for cyber frog our
seller name is cyber frog9 we ship same
day that you order you'll have it in a
couple of days thanks for listening
comicscape.org and then follow me on
Twitter at ethanvansgiver
if you want to follow me you can follow
me on Instagram and on Twitter
desk we've gotten both remember pop
culture crisis is Monday through Friday
3 P.M Eastern Standard Time that is noon
Pacific right here on YouTube me and
Mary talk about pop culture celebrities
movies all that good stuff come hang out
with us just follow me at Ian Crossland
and I just want to shout out Carter
banks for his epic uh production of
Bright Eyes he did a lot of the work on
that he did a lot of the harmonies too
so I mentioned that I did vocal harmings
on it Tim myself Carter we all did vocal
harm and he's on it uh it is magical it
was really fun to work with Carter did a
lot of work on that I'm kind of feeling
like I would love to do a sound garden
cover with Phil Labonte for like our
next song we've been listening to
Soundgarden before the show
Chris Cornell good I want to call him
Jesus Jesus Christ pose wasn't that a
was that a sound garden song or is that
Pearl Jam no that's that's that song I'm
pretty sure Jesus Christ posed that guy
man what a what a lot all right all
right let's move this out you guys
follow me at Kellen PDL hey I love this
was like one of the best Fridays so far
this was an awesome conversation and
yeah if you like conversation like this
watch pop culture crisis that's what
it's all about and I am on there every
Wednesday so yes Kellen PDL thanks guys
we will see you all this weekend with
our clips and Monday when we're back for
the show thanks for hanging out we'll
see y'all then